Muay, Muay, Boo.
Boo.
Minto, do you know what today is?
Hard to say it.
Thank you.
April 30th?
Wow, Boo again welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Boo.
I sent this super chat because it's pink.
I was about to say it's been one year ago, but actually it
has not been a year.
It has not been a year.
And actually, I'm using the same one.
And it smells, it's warming up right now.
it the the my hot glue gun and I keep smelling it and I keep
smelling burning and I'm like oh that's scary do you
remember what day it is today myth it's actually my birthday
Cortex happy birthday!
happy happy birthday thank you so much for the beep thank
you thank you thank you happy birthday yeah as you can see
It's still pink.
It's still pink!
After all this time.
Still pink.
It's pink!
For those who don't know, I have made puppets on stream
before.
You may remember Where Doki?
with why she looked dead where doki you may remember um an
insed stream sorry insed I think I drank dust
insed stream um I was like oh I bought this hot glue gun
because it's pink because when I went to the hot glue guy
and I was originally looking at the pink one and I was like,
it's so cute that it's pink!
And then I was like, no I have to get the one that's mint
but then I was like in my brain I remember wanting to get
the pink one and so I said it's pink.
I'm streamed in front of everybody.
Now everybody thinks I'm colorblind.
Everybody thinks I'm colorblind because I said my very I
think I drank dust
hold on I have this is gonna look insane probably sorry I
have my bag of voice stuff that's not a voice thing that's
milk can How did you get in there?
How did you get in there?
This is one of my favorite candies.
It's so...
I'm gonna have this instead.
It's a milk candy.
See?
I think this is my last one.
Joshua, thank you!
Pass my two month training for my new job.
Congratulations!
Congrats!
The reason I think I drank dust is because I took a sip and
now I'm coughing.
Look at that.
These are great.
Mintia Voice is so good.
This I have some, it's a cough drop.
Cough drop.
And then I have, every time I go back to Japan, I buy more.
They're like honey and...
Honey
and...
What's the other thing other than honey?
Honey and...
I don't think so.
Marco!
What is it?
I don't remember.
And then also...
If you want the most intense...
What's wrong with me today?
Sorry.
If you want the most intense...
This stuff will literally make your throat go numb.
This?
Intense pain relief?
Oh, it's backwards.
But it's real.
Soothe and numbs sore throat.
If you ever have a sore throat...
Severe.
It has a benzocaine in it.
This stuff is crazy.
Local path.
It is backwards, hold on.
I can fix it.
Oh!
I fixed it.
I didn't even know that it was backwards.
Hello everybody.
I'm nervous.
We will be making more hand puppets.
Last time I was only able to make two.
Today I want to make three.
I want to make three whole puppets.
How long did it take me last time I don't remember?
Quite a while, I think.
A year?
No one didn't.
Am I making myself to do to my my me yes Yes, I'm making me
to actually everything here is all for me.
Look I got my gold ribbon and I have brown and I have skein
and I have I realize I think I got too light of a blue.
my bad and I also I think maybe I am colorblind because
these are two different shades of white so I think this one
will use for my hair my hair and this one will be for my
dress and then and then for my hair hair I will like so to
make the gradient you know what I mean I'm gonna bite that
finger you have to make yourself cute or I booze will riot
yeah actually I do have to make myself cute because these
puppets will be auctioned they will be auctioned at fan
yourself a one only ever male tensetsu hand puppet made by
me and the proceeds go to charity the charity is make a wish
it's hilarious
fan of my in California greater
Bay area So, yes!
Greater Bay Area.
It is not for...
For a sec.
Hold on.
My hot glue gun fell over.
I don't want to cause any fire.
It was on the plastic.
I don't want to cause any fires.
Scary.
Okie dokie!
Um
I feel like I had something else to say and I don't
remember.
I don't remember.
So sorry.
And for today I have possessed a living being so that I can
purposefully touch everything physical.
So thank you persons who body I have possessed Thank you.
Thank you.
Let me put all my stuff down here that I...
So first of course, we start with the base and then I will
cut it out and then we will go go go go and then from there
continue.
Should we make myself first or save me for last?
Should we...
Should I go first or save it for last?
First?
Okay.
I thought so too.
I do have...
A little...
So for anybody who's just like...
Who is she making right now?
Right there.
Our reference.
So what I will do...
Hold on, I have to look at...
Okay.
hot dog hot dog oh oh no i have to put the notifications
above today's my birthday yeah paul said happy birthday glad
to have you as my oh she we've brought you've brought so
many wonderful things into my life such as what the game
though i still gotta practice way more to get better you got
it's about the passion it's not about being good you don't
have to be good what the game is It's just about supporting,
you know?
It's about the passion in your soul goes, you know?
And you dance it out.
Can't wait to see you, Vicky, and Phoebe at Oshia playing.
Thank you!
That's this weekend even.
Happy Big Shell Day.
Happy Big Shell Day!
Oh my gosh, I'm so jealous of everybody who has a birthday.
Um.
on April 30th.
How big did I make a donkey?
I'm so embarrassed.
I know it's not my actual hand, but like...
It's embarrassing.
Okay.
So probably if I did this way, it's okay too.
Yeah, okay, cool.
Oh, there's already stuff on me.
Okay.
Lay Sharpie.
Oh, you guys, I had such a strange day today.
Do you ever have those days where you feel like...
You feel like...
The day just happened and you don't know what you did?
You know what I mean?
Or do you know what I mean?
I woke up and I was feeling strange.
And then...
I...
I switched out my winter clothes for my summer clothes since
it's starting to feel like more warm outside.
And then...
And then I was like, wait, stream is happening?
Since when?
I was like, whoa.
What did I do today?
It was such a strange...
I feel so strange.
So if I'm a little like...
That's probably why.
Today was 1 p.m.
and I didn't even realize...
Yeah, you've been out of it too.
Is this a side effect of possession?
Well, I'm the one who possesses.
Watching King Kong and this girl is arguing whether he
climbed the Chrysler Building or the Empire State Building.
What do I do?
Take her home!
It's meant to be.
Wait, let me wait.
Okay, yeah, they're lined up.
I was in a complete brain fog yesterday.
So I know how you're feeling.
It's so weird, right?
Say it's Empire State.
Yeah, what does she say?
Actually, King Kong Climb...
Oh, gosh.
King Kong Climb's...
What?
Godzilla Tower.
It's the Chrysler Building.
Wait, I was literally about to say the Empire.
Empire State Building.
No.
I'm going to look at it.
I'm Googling it.
No, Susie climbs the Empire State Building.
You are all rows.
You guys are all rows.
Are we talking about King Kong or Donkey Kong?
Donkey Kong climbs...
Oh gosh.
He climbs...
What's her name, Paulette?
We're such egotistical, Ibu.
Frogbert and Ibu had a baby.
They move very fast.
How does it look?
It looks more like Frogbert.
than Ibu.
You didn't stream it?
I opened up the game and it said somebody wants to talk to
you.
And I was like, oh, okay, what's happening?
Literally, like an hour ago.
Who gave birth?
Well, it was Frogbert holding the baby.
So...
I don't know if that means anything.
Phew.
Does it have my eyes?
It looks...
It has your cheeks, though.
It has your cheeks.
Your face.
Cheeks.
And also...
Uh...
Her name is Frog Boo.
And she's getting along really well.
Like, Haley Julesman was, like, really interested in her.
And I was like, Haley Julesman, that's a literal baby.
It says she's zero years old.
Also, Ryden celebrated his birthday.
And that's your catch-up for for Tomodachi life.
Yeah, it's a girl.
It's a girl.
Good because I don't want you guys to become boy moms.
That's weird.
Cactus.
Me.
about my empty room.
Did you try feeding her gunpowder or?
Thanks for not impregnating chat, Frogbert.
I know it took her straight.
Alright.
Let's cut her open.
I might make this top a little bit bigger.
Or my big head.
Oh my goodness.
Stop flopping around.
Quit flopping around.
One thing I've been doing in my free time when I'm like
working on stuff, you know, just to have something on in the
background is listening to somebody explain every single
episode of Black Mirror.
Good luck to you and the rest of Dentato over at...
Was she uplinked this weekend?
Thank you!
Um...
A Black Mirror is a show.
Whatever happened to that show?
Like, why isn't it around anymore?
They just stopped making it, or...
Maybe I shouldn't have done it in the middle.
I think I have extra.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe I swallowed dust.
I was, you know, I exist in a haunted, abandoned maid cafe.
It's not exactly up to code.
And I was making it nice for stream, and I think dust got in
my drink, and I think I drank it.
This should be fine.
Let's try gluing it.
Flip her inside out.
Wait.
Oh, I just turned it upside down.
But...
Like so.
Make them keys.
Lick and whee!
Mademorable.
Ib.
around.
Wicked witch!
Maid mint.
M-M.
Wippin' around!
Wicked witch!
It has been a minute since that one!
I might need to move Koharu.
She's probably fine.
This is...
The Koharu mat that I waited like over a year for.
It was craziness.
I waited so long.
Oh, I already messed up.
Ouch.
I grabbed the glue with my fingers.
She got lost because it was during the time when like there
was...
What's the word?
Tariffs introduced.
And, uh...
So, I think she got lost and, like, what do we do with her?
She was already mid-transit.
I didn't have to pay for it.
She just arrived one day.
Oh, oh, oh.
It's getting all over.
Let's go!
Yeah, she got stuck in customs hell for a really long time.
There will not be glue on Koharu.
I really can't attend the auction but I want to donate to a
good cause anyway.
I am not the mega wish!
Why?
Are you calling me?
Are you saying that I am...
I am a child?
Riketan!
What the heck?
Thank you, but also what the heck?
What are you trying to say, huh?
Just a ghost in our cute pink glue gun.
Yeah, baby, yeah, baby.
Minto is a good cause too.
If the tiny shoe fits.
Now, I don't think I have, I mean, I don't think I have tiny
feet.
I can say that maybe I have smaller feet.
It's just like, you know, I can shop in the kids section.
No problem.
Oh, did you hear that pop?
That's crazy.
Birthday.
I've officially become middle age today.
What is a middle?
What age is middle age?
So to cope, I did what any man in my situation would do.
Eat dinner at a casino buffet.
Amtrak happy birthday!
30 plus.
So if 30 is the middle age, you die at 60.
Dang.
Humans are weak.
60.
turtles living to be like 200 years old maybe it should have
better evolved humans
life average life expectancy is 67.
no way what does that make me then i'm i'm i'm one of those
oh no i keep gluing it too far down
i just ouch ouch ouch send this money to the cute ghost
foundation how did you hear about that
uh-oh uh-oh team i might have messed up
team i feel like i did this before
i feel like i may have done this before I feel like I may
have done this last time.
Okay, hold on.
One moment, please.
Okay, I have Vicky's pile.
Oh my gosh, I am such a genius.
So Vicky has, like, polka dots, right?
On her sheet.
You see, like, on her skirt and on her cape.
And look what I got.
Isn't that...
I'm such a genius.
They're like little...
They're pearls and shinies.
Okay, hold on.
I have to look in Vicky's pile and make sure I have a base
for her.
If not, I royally screwed up, you guys.
I royally screwed up.
Wait.
No, I have...
Oh, it's not last!
Hold on, I have more.
I have more!
Yeah, baby!
I have, like, another pile of felt.
I have so much felt.
Let's try this again.
I mean, I could just trace this and make it even bigger.
I doubt anyone.
would actually wear these I'm wearing them I think I'll just
trace again my
hand bigger extend the pinky so I have like I would I when I
like hold my cups and see how my pinky just kind of like i i
am automatically fancy pants because like i'll hold my you
know i hold sorry you can see my teeth i hold my my pinky
out when i hold things
and it's because it's because my pinky like it's just kind
of you see how it's like just This sounds so funny.
You see how it's just like sticking out?
It's like straight?
If I like try to bend it, it
must stick straight out.
Today is my birthday.
Battle beetle happy birthday!
Oh, luckily for you, I do not have the power to snap.
So I cannot Thanos snap.
not be a little way.
Yeah, it like hurts too.
I massaged my pinky.
So yeah, I must, I must have my, if I bend like this, it's
fine.
But like, say these are down.
It's like a, ouch, ouch, ouch, it hurts.
It's my other side too.
I
think it's like a I think it's like a I don't know,
double-jointed or something But all my other fingers are
fine Do you need to practice your possession?
Maybe Am I not possessing good enough?
Who knows?
Yeah.
Where is...
Oh, Sharpie.
Sharpie.
Sure.
Okay.
And then down at my wrist, I need it big and thick and
chunky.
Maybe my thumb a little bit up.
She was simply born to be a fancy lady.
Yes, you are so you are.
This is
looking good.
This is looking big and promising.
Whoa!
Yippee!
That looks good.
Hands in the air!
Oi,
oi, oi, oi.
And then I'm even gonna cut it a little off too.
Like, you know, like so, you know, like so.
I smile cause I'm with you.
I thought about putting on like Metal Gear music today.
It wouldn't be so...
How the hell did I happen?
It wouldn't be so in theme, but...
It would be in theme for the day, not the stream itself, you
know.
I throw all used felt on the ground.
Ground!
Okay.
One thing I haven't thought of is, like, you know, how I
want to do the dress and everything.
I also am going to attempt.
Attempt is the key word here.
Attempt.
Front, end.
As much as the back as I can do.
What Metal Gear character would each member of Denza to be?
I think Phoebe would be Sunny.
Vicky would be...
Mito is pause.
I wanna be pause!
Vicky can be, uh...
What's her name?
Bird lady.
Shows up once and never shows up again.
Her name is escaping me.
Vicky!
Mint is Huey.
That's so wrong.
Cecilia!
Oh, paramedic!
No, I think...
I think Vicky could be...
Mer- Mer- Mer- Mmm.
Well, MGS music would be good.
You might not be able to contain your wiggles if you played
it today.
Might make it hard, Drew.
It's already been 40 minutes and I'm just cutting out a
bunch.
body this is bad guys this is bad
ground that should be better we'll just it'll be it'll look
seamless on the inside or you know we got to flip it out
it'll be fine these edges I mean um picket could be Merrill
yeah I think so all right
Kiss.
Let's go!
Steiner is the Fury.
Stream can't say goodbye to yesterday covered by Mipartope.
Thank you!
We have yet again been blessed with Mito hands.
Christmas came early.
What do you mean?
Alright.
The Fury.
That could be pretty good for him.
He gets so...
He's like...
He acts like a tiny man.
He gets more mad at...
He's so frustrated at that little thing.
Again.
I'll be like, Steiner, I want to do this thing.
And he's like, We had a meeting yesterday and we kept
spamming emotes.
And he was like, stop...
Oh, sorry.
I just realized I had the Vicky's up.
He's like, stop spamming the emotes.
I think even though I did this kind of low I think it's okay
I realized after I know he's such a
Stiders sounded like liquid snake there
He could Oh, oh, it's Okay I mean he could be liquid
Now whoever does get these I recommend you Treat them with
care If we got time left over, can we make a tiny Steiner
voodoo doll?
I might be able to make a Steiner doll.
Maybe not a puppet.
Okay, that should be alright.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay.
Yippee!
Is that the only hole?
Seems like it.
Dang it.
Where'd it go actually?
There it is.
Let's just do this.
Genius.
Yeah, I'm gonna cut this part a little bit.
Okay, cut my armpits.
Actually, that would be my shoulder, just kidding.
Okay!
Minto can get started on!
Woo!
Oh, okay.
First we shall...
Hmm, okay.
There's some little things I want to do, like I want to
make...
hair we could make a ribbon it's like the my neck ribbon and
maybe just some some strips we'll make them up okay we'll
make my neck ribbon and we'll make the base of my skirt and
then also a ribbon on the back where is my trusty sharpie
here you are okay all right will I be able to see this okay
yeah
Okay.
Oh, wow, you can see it so well.
That is my neck ribbon.
Okay.
And then, I know, sorry.
There's like a, I think my camera is like all weird with the
colors.
I'm not sure why.
I apologize.
I don't know why, especially with brown.
It really hates it.
For some reason.
And then the skirt.
Okay.
I'm measuring.
She wad.
Like so.
And then...
We could do that and then do like a little...
Thank you!
Your coffee bowl is huge.
Like could you...
You could drown in it at this point.
Be careful.
I almost just did.
I think like that is okay.
Let's start with that.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then...
Actually, we're not glowing right now, so I'll put this
away.
Ah!
We're fine!
Everything's fine!
Everything's A-OK.
Do not fret, friends.
Do not fret.
All right.
Cut out a little ribbon.
Actually, I said what I'm going to do is like do this.
Easier to control smaller pieces.
Hold on, I gotta get close to it.
Actually, I can't even...
Actually, no, it's better in the light.
I can't see my own drawing.
I'm fretting a moderate amount.
Failing to not fret.
Don't fret.
And don't threat either.
I can't see my drawing at all.
Wait, I think I messed it up.
I can't see my...
Oh my gosh, I really have dust in my throat.
Luckily, the ribbon is so small, I can make another one
easy.
And I'm also very confused how I drew this before.
Tiny ribbon.
Is it too small?
Let's try a little bit bigger.
Okay, hold on.
Before we do that, though, let me do my skirt.
Oopsie.
And then also, I have this to put on.
Wait, actually, how do I open this?
How do I open this?
Ribbon.
Vicky's keyboard does just chase after you.
No!
Comically timed.
I need a...
Let me scrap it.
How do I open this?
Oh, here?
I'm like trying to...
There.
There's like a...
Oh, I think I got it.
Oh, there's like a...
Oh, no, the tape broke.
There's like a...
Something holding it.
Seems a good size for the hair ribbons.
Even... I just...
I think even those need to be a bit bigger.
I make
my own solutions.
Celebrate it.
See, look how nice this looks.
Look at that.
I'm getting the ribbon is like coming under everywhere.
Shiny.
I did the little...
I don't think I'll be... I think I drew these, but I don't
think I'll be able to cut it because of the ribbon.
You know, it'll be too difficult.
So we'll just cut it across straight instead.
Anything like a ruffle, we're not doing.
This also could probably be good for the bottom of my apron,
or the middle of my apron.
So we'll keep the hot.
Okay.
Let's see how this looks.
I'm gonna...
We'll hold on to some scraps.
Ta-da!
We have the base of a skirt!
Okay, nice.
Good size.
Yeah, I'd say so too.
It's a little...
Okay.
Let me make another ribbon.
Oh, wait.
We'll do the rest of the ribbon.
We'll do it.
We'll do it later.
I'll do it later.
And I have a lot of mint.
A lot of that, sure.
Baby Kora, thank you so much for that vibe.
Gifted.
Thank you!
Which is the front and which is the back?
I don't know.
Which one looks...
Which one gives you front energy and back energy?
I feel like this looks like the front, maybe.
Maybe...
No.
Wait, yeah, maybe because that's the way I...
You know.
Like that.
Oh, no, though, I think I'll probably be wearing it with
my...
With my right hand, though.
I think so.
So I think it's gotta be this way.
Hello, hello.
Hugh, again!
The hole is back!
I thought I fixed you.
Oh my god, my hot glue gun has cat hair.
on it.
Have you ever considered the chance that it's haunted?
There could only be one ghost in my maid cafe.
There's not allowed to be any others.
Look it's sealed.
It's sealed.
You all see this now?
It's like a magic trick.
It's sealed.
It's sealed?
Yeah, this is the friend.
Because if I'm holding it like this, Hi guys, hello!
Hello!
Then this would be the friend.
There.
So even though the other way looks better, looks more
accurate, looks correct, this is the way we gotta do it.
Okay.
Alright.
Let me grab this, all this mint.
What I'm gonna do do is like cut off a big piece, a big
chunk.
If you guys can make a hound puppet, what would you make?
If I ever opened up like a commission,
what would you want me to make?
Or if you can make one?
Which you could.
That's so easy.
Sunny burp.
Thank you so much for the get-dead!
Minto, minto, minto.
I'm ignoring an answer.
Something wearable.
What does that mean?
Frogbird!
Limeu?
Steve from Minecraft Movie?
F-18.
I don't know if I can make it.
I don't know if I can make that.
I think I'm becoming an anti to this hot glue gun.
It keeps falling over.
Hi, Dad!
Oh, AstroBot!
Okie dokie.
Let's make...
I'm trying to decide how I want to do this.
Like, do I want to make it one big piece, you know?
This is tough.
You see there?
I'm trying to... I don't know what would be easiest.
You know?
I like this down.
This is the hips.
Also where the skirt is, you can kind of see it a little
bit.
Flares out like that.
Did you see the new Resident Evil trailer?
I did!
Why are we getting a new Resident Evil movie?
Armstrong with voice module to spam his voice lines.
I'm kind of confused how it is Resident Evil as well.
well yeah
it doesn't look like resident evil i don't quite understand
like i guess he's in raccoon city maybe i don't i don't
quite i don't quite know okay
uh sorry i'm still trying to figure out how i want to do
this okay
i commissioned you to make the most normal looking guy with
brown hair but like he has sunglasses and a dinosaur hoodie
on so he thinks he's cool He manages some VTuber group too,
I think.
I don't know.
It sounds above my...
Actually, it sounds below my pay grade.
Alright.
I think I'll go with doing the full outfit.
And then we can make the cuts.
skirt yeah okay okay okay
why is my outfit got to be so complicated those are not my
boobs by the way
wait no i went too far in okay hold on we can save this i
think it goes out yeah okay here
We don't need it to be longer than the skirt, but just for
the outline's sake.
Okay, that's a dress!
That's a dress!
Time to cut!
This felt is very soft compared to, like, the others.
I think the one issue I'm gonna, I might run into with
making my dress is...
thickness like stacking so many different fabrics on top of
each other you know
actually that works actually that's why i wanted to do it as
one big piece and then we can do the apron
and we'll make it work it doesn't have to be super detailed
It could get tricky.
It will get tricky.
I like your nails.
They're shiny.
Thank you.
I actually messed them up earlier, so I'm glad you can't see
them very well.
I'm glad you can't see them very well.
Let's see.
All right.
So then, probably like...
That...
And that looks even enough.
Don't look.
What's nice is we make this smaller and then we can take off
more if we need to.
Like so.
It looks kind of like Tinkerbell.
Kind of giving Tinkerbell a little bit.
Oh my gosh, wait, I just realized too I have little ribbons
on my...
We could just do this.
We could do pom-poms.
Ain't that so cute?
Like that?
Instead of the ribbons?
I'm gonna try flipping it upside.
Oh!
Oh, cut that part.
Cut that part.
Let's see if this actually lays as nicely on the other side
as it does.
Kind of!
It's like definitely made for this side.
Yeah.
I mean, I could just ignore it and say it's fine.
No, I wanted to do the side that doesn't have the Sharpie on
it.
But it's okay.
Okay, we'll save these for later.
Oh my gosh, if only this were thicker, it would be perfect
for my sleeves.
I think for my sleeves I'll just draw, I'll just...
Wait, it's already basically made!
I'll just trim
it down, I'll just trim it down.
voice you fell in love with with the real I don't think so I
don't know about that I don't know about them platonically
right I don't know if you can fall in love with somebody
from just their voice still giving tinko bail oh I didn't
look at the other side.
Well, we could just...
I could just do front and back, it's fine.
No, well, thank you so much for that!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much!
What the heck?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
It's like super baggy, but that's what I need.
I need super bag- so actually this might be perfect.
All right, let's trace it.
Perfect.
I will do it this way.
We might have to like...
Glue it while it's on the arm, though.
I think.
I saw someone comment earlier.
They'll be hearing the song in their dreams.
And that's good.
You should stream Densa to MVPs every year.
What about voice and hands?
Impossible.
What
a wonderful dream they must have.
I agree.
Oh wait, this is fine.
This is fine.
Electric daughter.
Sing on over with you.
Oh, what a thrill to be by your side.
There's nothing we can't...
Oh wait, I think I need to lower it a little bit.
See, cause like the arm peeks out a little.
I think it's okay.
Maybe if I'm like this instead.
Wait.
What we could do is I can like glue the very bottom and then
glue the rest.
I do want to make like the white here though.
So...
Do I know how to sing Vicky's Enka part?
I've never tried singing it.
So I'm not sure.
Yeah, I think this looks good.
Well, it's a little sticky out here, but that's okay.
That's my armpit.
Oh, oh no!
Koharu!
How could you betray me?
it pushed up in the corner and it shifted everything all
right I think like that is okay
are you guys seeing Minto are you guys seeing it
is the vision coming to live maybe once I add hair
oops maybe once I add hair it'll of butter real hair oh i'll
just uh you know but since i'm possessing a body it wouldn't
look like you know it would be the persons that imagine if i
possess you and give you a haircut you wake up and you're
like um hello what what the hell happened to me what the
hell is this
I could.
I'll do it to one of you guys someday.
If you cross me enough times.
Seeing Minto lower left.
Oh.
The dress fell off.
Minto.
Watch this too.
That looks like a Minto.
old googly eyes let's
we can do my hair so that we can imagine the thing about the
fat the felt that I got from I got like extra white felt
because I wasn't sure how much white I had left but this one
is thicker see hold on you can see how thick this is and
then see how thick that is it's so much thicker so I'm kind
of Maybe it's okay.
No, this is definitely not wider.
This is wider.
This is not it.
But my hair is like a little bit of like a gray tone, so
that's why I went with this one for my hair.
Hmm.
So...
But...
It's much thicker.
Oh no, I'm getting...
Okay.
I got glue on my fingernails.
It's a bit thicker, but I think it'll be fine.
I think so?
We could try.
All right.
Ooh, I'm scared.
Hold on.
Let me...
We'll trace the head.
Like so.
All right.
Now, draw.
I'm looking at myself.
Okay.
I can't, I wish I had, uh, I wish I had, uh, Nimmies as
well.
I don't remember how in-depth I went with the bangs.
We'll just go like that.
Like that, maybe.
Like that.
And then.
Hmm.
Nimmies is pretty accurate, was it?
I just realized.
I want to go higher, but I drew this.
Actually, we could do this.
Okay, hold on.
Guys.
What happened to Nimmy's?
Did you eat it?
I gave it to Nimi I gave it to her When we did her spring
concert I gave it to her I haven't done what we're doing
well Sorry kids I have a tooth extraction yesterday Oh my
goodness Brett Feel better Thank you for the super chats
Thank you, thank you Yeah, Nimi then ate it afterwards She
did it in one bite Like how in Toma That's life they go oh
my god i'm getting glue all over my fingers oh that's not
glue that's skin hold on
let's just go with this and see how it looks and then i can
always retrace it we
can always retrace it since all this white is just for my
hair so and then also of course
Ahugi.
We have our little bit here.
We'll start with the ahugi.
I almost want to make it bigger.
I could.
Fingers usually have skin on them, yes.
Oh, I'm just not used to it.
Sorry.
I'm fine, though.
Thank you.
Decided I wanted it a little bit more.
Pointed, and then...
Do you guys...
I think this is gonna be...
I think it's gonna fit first try.
Be believing right now.
It's gonna fit first try.
Believe, believe, believe, believe.
I just realized I didn't get anything for my hair accessory.
My little craw...
My golden crash.
X.
If this works, I might just keep it.
We'll see.
Okay.
Ooh!
Belly Eve!
Belly!
It'll look perfect!
First try!
First try, baby!
I feel like I might've made these little parts a little
long, but we shall also see.
Click, click, click, click.
Click, click.
Eek, ah, ah, it, oh, yeah!
Ah!
Not bad!
Baldness cured.
Thanks for being so cute.
Bubbly, I'm making a smile.
It helps me get through tough times loving Minto and Arbus.
Minto cute!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for that so much.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Oh my gosh, wish with all the gifted memberships today.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Are you guys seeing Minto now?
I wonder, I could, like, cut some little bangs.
Let me do that.
Where do I put my scissors?
Where do I put the scissors?
Yeah, oh, there they are.
There's three of her.
There's three of her!
We're multiplying.
I am Minto and you are too.
Yeah!
How do you guys feel about the amount of...
Hold on.
The amount of...
Uh...
Like Sharpie is on here.
You think it's okay?
Do you think it's alright?
I can draw maybe my air vents here a little bit.
And then also...
Wait, let's try it.
Let's try it on my tips.
It adds depth.
You guys say so.
Uh, you can see.
No, you can't.
It's too bright.
Nice.
Nice!
Yeah, you can see it from a distance more.
Yeah.
There's even like a little bit of a gradient I'm creating.
Ooh la la.
Oh, there's a cat.
What was that?
I've never heard that noise before.
Wait, did you guys hear that?
What was that?
Now that's what I call Minto.
Yeah, what was that beep?
I've never heard that before, ever in my afterlife.
The camera?
The video was getting too large, so we stopped recording.
Wait, it's been recording a video this entire time?
Why was it doing that?
Where did it record to?
Oh my gosh, it's been recording for a long time.
my oatmeal.
I'll delete it later.
That was strange.
Minto!
I accidentally messed up there.
I'm gonna just blend it out.
Blend it out, baby.
Blend it out.
Okay.
Yay!
Release the oatmeal cut.
No!
I'm scared to like draw more.
Because I feel like it'll look too messy.
That's okay.
It's okay how it is right now.
Alright.
And then...
I almost feel like I should have taken the...
drawn... traced this for this arm too.
Right now she's naked.
That's kind of crazy.
You little freakazord.
Running around with your arms up and being naked.
Where is her dress?
Oh, I found it.
Like so.
Okay.
What I want to do next is maybe we will do the other sleeve.
I know I'm a bit all over the place with her, but that's
okay.
I'm kind of just doing what feels right.
You know what I mean?
And then...
Actually...
What if...
like the bottom of this and then bottom of this yeah how do
I glue it is my is my question because my fingers are gonna
get green my fingers are green thank you thanks for keeping
me company as I unpacked the last of my stuff from this from
the hellish move of 22 Why?
What happened?
Alternate greed!
I have an idea.
Watch this.
Keep your eyes on the prize.
Keep your eyes peeled for my amazingness.
Wait, I think I messed it up.
Hold on.
Keep your eyes peeled.
Keep them peeled.
Peeling, peeling, peeling, peeled.
Wait.
Peeled.
They're peeled.
Okay.
You see?
I was like, how am I supposed to glue this whole thing down?
Well.
Little Aibu.
Alligil.
Everything is messed up.
Don't.
I have to do it.
Blood, sweat, and tears are going into these puppets.
If you see blood on your puppet, don't DNA test it.
I'm going to make it a bit longer, actually.
this piece and what I just got.
Can I unpeel my eyes yet?
Oh, it hurts.
Can you guys kiss it?
Can you kiss it?
It hurts.
It's a middle finger I used.
Thank you.
Okay.
Let's try it again.
Are your eyes peeled?
Are you ready to witness greatness?
Unlike you have ever seen before.
No, stop it.
Stop it.
Stop moving.
Please.
I wish I had something to keep it in place.
But unfortunately, I don't.
Alright.
Oh, it moved.
Okay, it's fine.
No, it moved.
Ah, it's not fine.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
I fixed it.
Stick it down.
You see what you might want to keep a bowl of ice water to
the side to dip your fingers in if it happens again.
Less likely to get blisters if you cool it off fast.
I'm ruining my gaming fingers.
They're all green.
She said, my name is Binto, and I take that literally.
Literally.
Okay.
This is very meticulous, everybody.
Yeah.
Actually, oh, I have to see this.
And then fix it.
Okay.
Uh, I keep messing it up.
It's like one shot that I have.
I get it right and make it look good.
Ow!
If it looks bad, well, um, it's bad.
Everything's cool.
Everything's bad, okay?
Let's see.
She's got pink fingers now.
You know the story about the girl whose boyfriend made pizza
and when it was ready, he took it out of the oven with his
bare hands?
You were the boyfriend?
When I worked at a pizza place...
They expected us to take it out with our bare hands.
Oh, it almost looks good.
It just kind of sticks up.
See?
My name is Grinto because she's green and she makes me
green.
What?
Yeah, when I worked at a pizza place, they were like, oh
yeah.
I was like, how do I get the pizza out?
And they were like, oh, we just grab it.
Well, my idea wasn't perfect.
I guess it almost worked, though.
It made this part easier.
Everything else was the worst in the world.
Yeah!
Oh, I have to do that two more times.
I love that whoever gets this, you know, you're seeing it
kind of like, I'm not on a very good webcam right now.
And then whoever gets this in person is going to be like,
oh!
They're gonna be like...
Oh, that's...
That's not how I looked in the video.
Ooh, what's...
There's still hair on this.
Yeah, they're gonna see all the cat hair!
They're gonna be like, Oh my god.
It's hideous.
Alright, well let me just finish these last two ones then
since I've already I'm already in this deep look I got I got
glue on my thumbnail
adds to the value it's truly handmade I wonder what other
people will contribute to the charity auction because what
if it's just like oh this person donated a Birkenbag and
this person this VTuber donated yeah the world's biggest
diamond a brick
and this VTuber donated her her trash
I'm wondering if I should do the same thing.
I will, but I'm going to do it a little more easily.
We'll do this first.
And then we'll fold it over.
I don't know.
I was trying to do something.
Ouch.
Yeah.
Doesn't matter what they'll donate.
It'll have no soul at all comparison to this.
Oh, this is all soul.
I'm getting ectoplasm all over it.
I'll spray it with my perfume even.
Well, actually, I have to give it to someone.
Steiner so I will spray it with my perfume but after I give
it to him it's out of my hands if it smells bad you can
blame him hey minty mama a while ago I made a wish to a gin
and a bottle to record you as the prettiest lady to ever
appear on video for all to see hopefully you got it and that
it didn't twist the wish into something else.
I don't know.
I think it backfired.
I think it was a twisted wish.
Ouch.
My fingers are starting to go numb.
Or not numb.
Raw.
Push
it down with the sharpie.
Number two.
Oh,
I glued it to my desk.
I wasn't kidding about that.
ice water.
It's fine!
I don't have much of the ribbon left.
Well, for now.
Until I have to put it... Well, I have to put it all in the
bottom here.
But that's easy.
We're fine.
Everything's fine, everybody.
Don't panic.
I just got here, so I'm sorry for a million people already
asked.
Do you know what day it is today?
Uh, April 30th?
I didn't show you all my little men's!
Wait a second.
Oh, I found them.
Hold on one second.
I'm gonna grab the ones from inside my cabinet.
And then also, the ones in my bag!
Also for April 30th, I feel like he should be on stream.
Oh.
Okay, hold on.
Let me gather all my little men's.
I swear I had...
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, okay.
My little bans and naked briden.
I put him as...
I put him...
Okay.
I have him naked and ashamed.
And then I have my snake nendoroids smoking a cigarette.
Look at all my rexes.
We can...
Okay, we can decorate for April 30th.
I'll get rid of my rexes.
We don't need those.
We have Rays.
And him.
Decoration, decoration!
Also, since I got like the pre-order, they came with this
fancy base.
Alright, Naked Ryden.
Box.
Ray.
Very nice.
We can't have snakes though because he's MGS1.
Do you have Emma?
I do?
Well, I have another figure of Emma.
I have a bunch of Metal Gear, or MGS2 figures, actually.
But we'll just decorate with this.
We'll just put another... Can you even see him?
Yeah, you can.
You can see him a little bit.
And we'll put another one right over here, too.
Another one.
And another one.
Army of Rays.
Censor.
Censoring.
Censor, censor.
Okay.
Did my tumblers run the claw game ever arrive?
They did, actually.
They did.
Snake in the fetal position.
Guys, I love collecting little men, little men.
I love...
Guys, I have to pee.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
I think I got...
A lot of the green off.
Thank you guys for those super chats.
Thank you.
See?
I think a lot of the green is off.
Okay, let's do this one.
Do you like the decoration for April 30th?
It's pretty good, I'd say.
Are you guys fans?
Oh.
Thank you.
guys fans nice and clean pretty good yeah i think it's so
funny that they included a naked ride on like body oh my god
i did get something though in tomodachi life today that is
so oops i did not mean to do it all the way across but
that's okay that is so perfect it looks just It's like a
sneaking suit.
So I will be giving...
I think it looks more like Raiden's sneaking suit than...
Snakes though.
Oh, what do you mean sing?
What should I sing?
Please, please.
Vito, sing for me.
Please.
You could say please.
Actually, you didn't even say please.
You didn't even say please.
We're manners.
Yay!
All three done!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Please, please sing Vituper.
Please.
They said it was their birthday earlier.
I didn't see that.
Happy birthday!
Oh, gosh, I'm so sorry.
George, I'm so sorry.
Happy birthday.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry!
Happy birthday!
I'm so sorry, I didn't even see it.
I apologize.
I could sing.
We could do karaoke, puppet making.
Looks like her hair...
Oh no!
My hair!
My wig!
All right.
Yes.
Good.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, let's do...
Before I get rid of the...
What?
Is there other places?
I think I'll just do the...
Okay, I'll do the ribbon.
I think I'll do it up top.
And I'll do it on the bottom.
I think that will be the most that I can do it.
You know you aren't in Japan right now, but I still hope
you're having a good golden week.
Or goshi week if you are.
Umamusa, my friend.
Yeah, I haven't seen anything for Golden Week.
Actually, though, that's a lie.
I was able...
Some places have Golden Week, like, some of my favorite
fashion brands have Golden Week sales going on.
And that's exciting for me.
So, I have been partaking in that.
Steam has a Golden Week sale.
No way, really.
Is it, like, JP Games?
Skisors?
My tiny details.
I'm making this so...
You can tell I'm caring about this much, you know, because
I'm making...
I'm trying to make it really nice.
Even if I don't get to get to everybody's today, like
everybody's puppets, I will finish them off stream and I'll
post about it.
But, um...
That should be fine.
It's not completely accurate.
Because there's, like, a little bit of a strip.
But that's okay.
You could do it speed- I feel like I'm faster than last time
though.
It's been two hours and I haven't finished one, but that's
okay.
But I still feel like I'm faster than last time.
I'm like focused.
I'm- I'm like this is a- this is what I gotta do.
Maybe I should have made like the hand bases of everybody
off streamed it.
Made it first.
Focus.
I'm focused.
What the?
Sticking up!
You son of a...
You little beach, you beach!
Mine might be the most detailed to do.
I think...
Maybe.
I think Vicky's is also quite detailed as well, but we We
have the cheat.
I have the polka dots.
The polka dot cheat.
Oh, it keeps sticking up.
Why would you do this to me?
How could this happen to me?
Wait.
There's some glue there.
I don't want you to see the glue.
Whoever gets this, I don't want them to see the glue.
They probably will see the glue.
They'll probably see the glue.
Just a little bit.
That's okay.
Just don't look too hard.
Don't inspect.
You like my nail polish?
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
And there's a little bit of glue right there and there.
And then every time I pull off some glue, it's pulling off
some of the felt.
I feel like I'm making it go bald.
Tinkerbell.
Wait.
Where's the skirt?
go where'd the skirt go oh there's hiding off to the side
wait wow tinkerbell it's coming together ish
let's also do wait this is the wrong white felt where's the
other white felt
This is the thick white belt.
And where did I put it?
Where did I put it?
Oh, I found it.
We could do the dress, I think.
Why does this feel different?
Or...
Yeah, they're different.
They're different.
Okay.
Thank you!
Thank you, Luloa!
Yeah!
Thank you so much!
Alright.
So we need to leave a little bit at the top here.
And then it kind of just...
I'm just gonna make a big ol...
shape.
Have you been to the current Miku Expo?
No, I have not.
I have not.
Not that I'm not.
I could put another white strip here too.
Probably.
I'll figure that out when we get there.
Trying to get more glue.
I'm purposefully making it a little bit bigger.
Do you know what date is?
Thursday?
Cut.
Cutting time.
Wait, May is tomorrow.
It's gonna be May.
No way!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, it's already May?
Oh, golly.
I never thought about, like, April 30th, you know, with the
whole meme.
I never thought of it being like, oh yeah, and then the day
after is the first of May.
Oh, I made it a little small, I think.
From here.
I think it's okay, though.
I will shorten the actual round part, though.
I will shorten down here.
That's okay.
This is handmade with minto love.
It doesn't need to be perfect.
I'm just being a bit of a perfectionist.
Maybe because I feel like a pressure.
Because it's like, you know.
There's multiple reasons for pressure.
That looks good, though, I think.
That looks good.
I wonder if I have any more pom-poms.
I could just do like two and...
Oh, wait.
Let's try to test this.
Pom-pom.
Pom-pom-pom-pom.
Yeah.
And then two more blue pom-pom.
I have one.
One pom-pom.
Pom-pom.
And another pom-pom.
bum how
are we feeling about those looking great boss thank you you
guys you think it's looking great thank you bum bum we
do need to put some white under here so actually we can
probably move up i'll move our pom-poms and we can actually
scoot the whole thing up a little bit Like so, and then I'll
put a white layer underneath.
What I think I'll do is I'll do the front of everybody
today, and then I'll do the back on my own.
Like that.
I think so.
What are you trying to hide?
Oh my gosh, I'm going to put my signature on the back,
actually.
I'm going to sign it, like a true artiste.
Artista.
Let's do this a little bit.
I have to start gluing these down.
A song?
What song do you want, George?
Um, um.
We'll be caught in three hours.
What happens in three hours?
I wonder if I could...
Oh wait, I'm going to test.
I'm going to test drawing a little ghost you got.
Here, I'll sing a song.
The wheels on the bus go round and round, round and round,
round and round.
The wheels on the bus go round and round, all through the
town.
Oh, it kind of...
It's a little fuzzy, but it works.
Oh, through the town, boys!
Here, I can even... Here, hold on.
The wipers on the bus... Oh, what the...
Oh, sorry.
I opened up Carafine and it was just like...
Oh!
Wait, it refreshed my camera!
Why did it do that?
Wait, what the heck?
Weird.
You've never heard the wipers go there.
that noise.
Let's see.
Um...
on the wheels on the bus.
They're so loud.
The wheels on the bus go round and round, round and round,
round and round.
The wheels on the bus go round and round all through the
town.
The doors on the bus go open and shut, open and shut, open
and shut.
The doors on the bus go open and shut, all through the town.
The people on the bus go up and down, up and down, up and
down.
The people on the bus go up and down, all through the town.
The babies on the bus go where, where, where, where, where,
where, where, where, where, the babies on the bus go where,
where, where, all through the town.
The mommy's on the bus go shush shush shush shush shush
shush shush shush The mommy's on the bus go shush shush
shush all through the town
The wheels on the bus go round and round Round and round,
round and round The wheels on the bus go round and round All
through the town Drivers slow down
That one's for you, George
Why is this so anxiety inducing?
Please let this be a normal field trip okay give me one
second let's uh i guess oh i just gotta cut a little strip
of white for right here little strip easy peasy and slip it
right there like so and then like that and that should be a
minto Dress.
Oh.
Uh-huh.
What do you guys think I should have my facial expression
be?
Oh, I still gotta make the other bow.
I just remembered.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, thank- oh my gosh.
Go pull.
Thanks for the third ever Super Chat!
I loved it.
Three hours, the cancer- No!
No!
George!
She's my...
Framoo!
With the mint on all way!
Baby shark next please.
I'll think about it.
I shall think about it.
Why is my... I feel like my camera looks strange.
Sorry if it looks strange.
Okie dokie.
Artichoke.
facial expression like ah well i yeah i could do that let's
see wait
all right so other things we gotta do oh my gosh is these
the that and white ruffle here and other sleeve and white
ruffle the ball rest of my hair The Minto on the bus go,
Moibu.
Vicky's go, it's Tuesday, isn't it?
Phoebe's go, oh, I thought you were making me sing it.
Phoebe's go, Ohachi.
And then a little, and then the ribbon, and then the white,
and then we're done with Minto.
We're done with me.
Oh, I can do this.
Oh my gosh.
I'm such a genius.
I'm a genius.
I'm a genius, I'm a genius.
No detail left behind except a lot of them, obviously.
No detail left behind except many of the details.
Okay.
For now, we'll take all of this off.
Strip her.
She is naked.
What I got?
can do after is I'll just glue this all together and then uh
but for now let's make the other sleeves or let's do the
white hmm I'm trying to decide what do I want to do wait let
me throw a white or cut a white strip like that and then I
can just go like this
detailed so detailed maybe because it's me i mean obviously
i'm gonna try and be as as detailed for febi and vicky as
well but i feel i feel like a pride you know that i'm like i
have to i have to i i this is my outfit i wanted to look as
accurate as possible you know
yes oh it's silent i'm so sorry
Oh, my hand's shaking!
AHHHHH!
Free-handed.
Hold on, let's fix this one.
There we go.
Just a little bit of fudge.
Never hurt anybody.
Clean these up, clean these up, clean these up.
Hopefully this fits.
We'll see.
Yay!
I hope I'll be in your heart as you were in mine.
Oh, George, I'll never forget you.
Yeah.
Let's do, like...
If I start there...
Good enough.
Okay.
Okay, cool.
Then we can push it up a little bit.
And we'll do this.
We'll glue it on this side first.
Some
glue came out.
Some glue came out.
Oh, sorry.
It hurt more than I expected it to.
Ugh.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
Everything's fine?
Don't worry about it.
My tummy's starting to growl.
I got Taco Bell waiting for me.
Oops.
That didn't quite work out as I thought it would.
Hmm.
Hold on.
Maybe like, uh, this way instead.
That works better.
Ah!
I don't need ice water!
I can tank it!
Okay.
One second.
There we go.
That's much.
better and this side too
very good my claws my claws big matey claws currently if
hacking bro oh she up like this weekend i hope everyone
attending has a great time looking forward to the dentist of
concert yeah thank you trash bow hopefully see you at the
meet and greet if not see you at the concert
Yeah, I'm gonna use this bad boy to wipe that extra glue up.
It's gonna be so fun when I clean my desk later and I'm
getting rid of little...
It feels like spider webs, right?
It feels like spider waves.
But it's just little bits of...
Little bits of, what's it called?
Hot glue.
One sleeve down.
concert's gonna be amazing i'm nervous we picked some fun
songs though
what am i not nervous though what am i not nervous you know
wait this way yeah yippee
put your hands in the air like you just don't care i was
helping oh my gosh wait i could glue it down like this wait
wait what do you guys think do you think i should glue it
down kind of like so that's a little floppy
she might be a genius i know oh my gosh we were in our
meeting yesterday and i was like i was i was talking about
the puppets and we had some other idea with the puppets and
i was like And someone, not Steiner, but someone else at
Setsunawa was just like, Mint, you're really smart.
And I was like, thank you!
Thank you!
Like, I feel like I have crazy ideas, but they work
sometimes.
As always, Mint being nervous equals a sure sign of
impending amazingness.
It looks like a dinosaur like...
Like claws.
So cute.
Specifically it was not Steiner.
Yeah, specifically it was not Steiner.
Okay, let's do the other sleeve.
Big, meaty claws.
Where are my scissors?
Actually, I'm just gonna use...
Actually.
What?
Oh, I can fold it in half.
Let's see.
Fold it this way.
If I fold it this way...
Perfect.
Can I still be in my scissors?
Where could they be?
I have so much stuff everywhere.
Wait, where are they for real?
Did they fall?
I didn't hear them fall.
I didn't notice them fall.
Hello?
Hold on.
Let me check the ground.
They were under my butt.
That's my bad.
Okay.
Let's see.
I'm just gonna kind of do the same thing where I like draw.
Okay.
So it's about the length.
length of this is actually kind of what we need to go with
and i'm gonna okay i do want it taller so that i can do the
same thing so about he about down here seems good i'd say
for our second sleeve
like so and then like that it's a little big let me like
I'll trim from here alright my years of making cosplay
really pay off in these types of streams I'd say I'd say so
yeah okay boom boom
Like, that is okay, I think.
It looks pretty even.
Could even be a little shorter.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
What's up, Mint?
Hi!
Hello!
Oh!
I dropped the other one.
Where did my blue ball go?
Oh!
I think it actually fell on the floor.
That's okay.
Okay.
Then, let's do, once again,
the white...
I'm, like, misplacing everything.
Oh, here, I found it.
We'll do the same thing with here as we did here.
I do want to kind of change the shape a little bit.
A little bit.
I feel like it's so... it doesn't, like, have any...
diagonal.
You might see it pit a little bit, like armpit, that's okay.
Yes, okay.
All right.
Yeah.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Nice, nice, nice.
Glue.
Glue, glue, glue.
Great, even.
So true!
Sorry, I forgot I was in a chat of equal minds.
I didn't forget.
How could I forget?
Alright.
This side.
I'm gonna put another stick in.
Of glue.
Glue stick.
Ouch!
Don't touch that part.
It's hard.
Push, just like the Aibu had to do when he was giving birth!
Push Aibu!
I thought Frogbert was the mama.
I said Frogbert was holding the baby.
I said nothing else.
You all inferred that because...
I don't know, go look at a couple that is like a man and a
woman in Tomodachi life and see which one is holding the
baby.
And if the one that is holding the baby is the father, you
gave birth.
You gave birth.
Check it.
Can you make heart hands?
How do you want the heart hands?
Do you want them like this?
Or do you want them like this?
Or do you want them like...
Wait, I just did that.
Like this.
and I'm like this do you want them like
I feel like I'm missing one this this this this
another strip we cut another strip
I feel like I'm taking so long on myself I feel really bad
we're educating new eyeballs about your hand trick could you
please could you find them Oh my gosh, my hand trick!
Are you guys ready?
I have this special hand trick I can do.
Not many people can do it.
You can try, but I don't know.
You have to have special fingers like me.
I can do my special trick.
Are you ready?
Here we go!
So cool, VTuber.
Okay, here's my actual hand trick, okay?
And I'm serious about the...
about many struggle.
Many struggle, many try, and many fail.
Yeah, thank you so much.
We love music!
Thank you!
Okay, here's my hand trick.
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle,
wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
I don't even need my eyes open.
I can do them close.
La la la la la la da da da da.
Yeah.
Very cool hand trick.
Do not steal.
Are you impressed?
Little Ibu?
I was saying glitches, thank you so much for the fun, good
to thank you.
That was pretty good.
I know.
I know, I know.
All right.
New Clouge.
Ouch.
Let's put it a little bit.
Uh-oh.
This feels like it's...
I can probably glue it.
It's like shifting over a little bit on this side, but I
think I can just glue it to where it's not.
Okay.
Hot glue gun.
Wow.
Wait.
Did my other stick fall or did I just...
No, it must have fallen.
There's no way I already used all of it.
That'd be crazy.
I must have lost it.
You didn't tell me you were a water bender.
I know.
It's so impressive.
You're like, I've never seen anything before in my life.
How is she so cool?
It's funny because, like, I've just done that ever since.
It's forever ago.
Like, for so long.
I never thought of anything of it.
Check other Tomodashi life playthroughs.
One with Mario and Peach, and yes, indeed, Mario is holding
the baby.
Draw your conclusion from that, Chet!
We're a mother now.
Congratulations.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I kind of messed up.
This one is, like, thicker than this one.
You think it's okay?
Wait, I really messed up.
I wasn't paying attention.
I wonder if I can undo it.
Ugh.
Pull it apart.
I have to re-glue.
I think I made it just too skinny in general too.
Oh!
No felt!
Okay.
We're fine.
Maybe.
Little slight casualty.
I'll put the ugly side on the back.
Just like a whole glue chunk right there.
Mother's Day soon, Minto.
Yeah?
What, you think Frogbert is gonna get you anything?
Be for real.
Tell me right now that you think Frogbert would actually get
you anything.
Yes, Frogbert loves me?
Toxic relationship.
Hopefully this works.
Oh, oh, barely, but it works.
It barely works.
Like, the line is very, very small.
Holy cow.
Nice.
Yippee!
So, if Minky and Snake and Tomodachi live, do get Prego,
then...
Don't talk about that!
Wait, what would the baby look like?
I could show you what Frogbo looks like.
But I have to pull up my switch and everything.
You might have to wait.
We'll see how much I get done on this stream.
If I get a good amount done, I'll show you the baby.
So you have to encourage me to do good.
And get stuff, and get puppets made.
I think...
Last time too, the puppets weren't nearly as detailed, so
I'm like, oh geez.
What have I gotten myself into, you know?
But it's okay, they will get made.
On stream, off stream, whatever.
Are you jealous of us in Frogbert?
Oh!
I did forgot to tell you!
So then Ibu went to Minke and was like, I want to live with
Minke.
What should we talk about?
We talked about wet t-shirt contest.
But, like, don't you live with your Frogbert?
Why would you want me there too?
I think a little managitoire is happening.
Also, Gengar went.
And there's the baby.
Actually, the baby, like, grew up immediately.
It was kind of freaky.
You can do it.
Make the felt ham puppet thingy.
Thank you!
You know that frog ain't loyal.
You're the one asking another Ghost to move in.
What does that make you?
Why are her hands like that?
Uhhhhhh...
Ooh!
Spooky!
What I think I'll do is I'll finish up what we have.
And I can do, like, the other details, like the ribbon.
Oh, my gosh, I have so much to do.
I could do the ribbon and the back of my hair.
And also on the back of my dress.
I might not do the back.
I don't know.
We'll see how much I get done.
Oh, oops.
Phoebe found out on stream today what a wet t-shirt contest
is.
I told her to remember to think.
She didn't even know!
No, no wonder she wanted to-
Oh, Phoebe!
I always thought, like, wet t-shirt contests were, like, all
the rage and everything.
Everybody did them.
You know?
Like, back in the day, I always thought that, like,
everybody was doing a wet t-shirt contest.
I guess I was wrong.
I'm so sorry.
I took her up, Phoebe.
I'll do her next.
This is why I wanted to start at 6.
delivery man for not delivering until so late.
Oh no!
It tore it too.
No, it tore it too.
Oh, it looks terrible.
Why did it break?
What were you waiting on?
All the mint felt.
I had gone to my craft store and they didn't have any.
I was standing in the aisles of my craft store ordering
Bintfelt.
Oh, does it look so bad?
Oh, no, I'm so sad.
Why did it break apart?
Why?
Oh, I'm so sad.
I'm sorry.
Too skinny, skinny legend.
Skinny legend.
If you ever want to make a nice little...
See?
It kind of looks nice on...
It looks nice and even.
Just fold it over the edges.
Nobody will ever see it again.
It wasn't the hot glue.
It was...
I was holding it.
It wasn't the hot glue.
Maybe we can like...
Oh!
Oh, that looks better already.
Oh, that does look better.
I glued it a little bit.
Nice.
We should hold a contest at every con from now on.
I agree.
I think more people would be willing to participate.
They're all the rage, apparently.
Everybody's doing my t-shirt content.
Oh, I forgot to do the ribbon on this guy.
Shoot.
Minto and the never-ending details on my dress.
I mean, to be fair, like, I could be...
going really crazy like I could be adding more here actually
it looks pretty good maybe I'll do that later um I could be
adding so much more first time catching a stream hope you're
doing good thank you Sam welcome welcome welcome we're just
reviving we're making puppet all is well
I kind of can't wait.
This is making me want Halloween again though since the last
time I did this was during Halloween and I love doing like
Halloween crafts, you know.
There's so much fun to me.
So...
I would like Halloween to come back.
And Halloween means it's close to my birthday.
Or rather, my birthday means it's close to Halloween.
Other way around.
Oh!
At this rate we'll be here till morning!
I just, I'm a perfectionist.
What can I say?
I can't help it.
One of the things about this week's schedule is an hour
earlier of Minto streams, Minto comes sooner.
Hooray!
I know because I was like, I want to do stuff for a bit
longer this week.
like I'll just do long... I'll just... Ouch!
Start earlier.
But today was a bit of a bush.
Not bad.
It's okay.
I'm not ending stream anytime soon, though.
I could go for another hour or two.
Two if I eat.
I meant to say that this year is going by too fast.
When we wake up, it'll be October.
Wake me up when September ends.
The song.
I feel like my...
I wonder if it's the lighting in here.
My camera is like all funky looking.
Sorry.
Great dimension.
Well, I like these kinds of streams because I can also just
like...
I can chit chat, but also I'm doing something.
I feel productive.
With a...
Ghost interference.
It must be.
I did have to get some dance practice in today though.
Oh!
Sorry!
Ouch!
I didn't think that would...
I didn't think the glue was going to come through.
There we go.
It looks really clean on the camera.
It does not look so clean in person.
This one is also coming up.
Maybe it's a good thing that the camera is a little dinky
then.
Don't touch him.
Oh!
Hand stream with no glass.
Well, you know, it's like not my body.
Because I'm a ghost.
I just possess somebody.
If the hands look bad, it's not me.
You can blame that person.
Yes, yes indeed.
It's all those burns from the glue gun are just phantom
pain.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, what if they wake up and they're just like, why are my
hands like literally blistered and falling apart?
It's me.
Sorry.
I try to be like, you know, in and out.
Nobody can, nobody knows I was here.
Oh, this one's also coming up a little, you see.
It's fine.
I'll fix it later.
Now that's a Minto dress!
This looks like me!
I think.
That's kind of crazy.
I still need, obviously, my triangle.
Which we will do after I glue this on.
We'll make it.
Actually, I could do it right now.
Oh, well.
Let's do it with the white.
Also, I do want to draw on the little ghosty.
I just have to get all the fuzz off of the Sharpie.
Oh,
that's not so bad.
Yeah!
Let's draw.
Let's just cut a triangle.
I don't even need to draw it.
I'm just gonna cut from the corner.
Boyfect.
Almost.
A little more angular.
Angular, angular.
Nice.
There we go.
It's really coming together, I'd say!
I think it's looking pretty good so far.
Let's glue this part down too.
I can move it over a tad.
Wait.
Hee hee hee hee hee hee.
Oh,
oh, oh, oh.
Oh, we're fine.
Everything's cool.
Wait, don't mean don't.
Thank you!
Yes.
No.
Oh, I think it became a little uneven.
That's okay, though.
The whole thing's a little uneven.
Who am I kidding?
Okay.
I'm gonna glue this here.
My perfectionism is paying off.
It's a blessing and a curse.
Because, you know, things might end up looking good because
I'm like, oh, and what about this?
And then what about this?
But then at the same time, it makes things so much more
time-consuming.
I do... I do kind of want to do my twin tales.
But I'll do them later.
You'll see, I'll take a picture once I finish everybody.
with all the ultimate details and little bits.
Wait, I think I am a genius.
I have all these pipes.
What if...
Do I have a yellow one in here?
That's brown.
I thought I saw a yellow one here.
I see you.
Come, come, come, come.
I could do it for this thing here.
I could do it for that.
It already takes time, but it looks so nice.
Yeah, I think so too.
Like this.
I could do that.
Her hair is falling off.
It's so funny without the hair.
It looks so funny.
How far down do I want the head to go, actually?
Let me get the eyeballs again.
Trusting the process.
course and then I still have that mini bow I think I threw
it somewhere let me I was gonna say the mini the little
ribbon I did shoot that's okay I'll just cut another box off
this brown and
we'll just pretend like that and that should give me enough
for my mouth if it's like a that big
i'll do it i'll do it open open i'll do the open d
yeah okay let's glue my hair
oops ever did i realize she's oh she's naked
she's naked underneath all that junk all that junk inside
that drug I'm a get-get-get-get-get-get-get-you-puppet.
Oh!
Snake!
Luckily, hot glue is very easy to get off sometimes.
Oh my god!
No!
Snake!
The box!
God, this is priority number one.
Snake!
Yeah, he was in the splash zone.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's like not wanting to peel off.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Okay, I got it.
Oh!
I'll put him in the bag.
Oh, my goodness.
I got him.
I got it.
Everything's fine.
All is fine.
All is good.
All is jolly.
We're safe.
This part hasn't been glued.
Okay.
All right.
Oh my goodness.
It looks so good so far.
Yay.
I'm like skimping out on a bunch of details, like the little
details on the arm, warmers, and like my sleeves.
Uh, that's okay.
That is A-okay.
Um, let's see.
Alright, about like this.
And then I do need the ruffle on the bottom.
Already looks so much like me.
Thank you.
The dress is on.
baby the dress is on oh my gosh there's so much hot glue
everywhere ah every time I feel like I get it all there's
more and more and more oh
I think I went too far oh shoot oops there's all this glue
right here ah it's okay because when I make the back of the
dress and everything it will be it will But for now, we'll
just wipe it.
We'll just kind of...
We'll just do that for now.
Let's do that for now.
Oopsie!
Okay.
We just won't do the same thing on the other side.
Let's just go...
To there.
Okay.
I need more glue stick.
Don't want the dress falling off at all.
Which, once I glue the back together, it should be
sandwiched, so it should be okay.
But for now.
Yeah!
Oh, and let's do my little dots, my little bows on here,
like I said I was gonna do.
There we go.
Two.
Yeah.
Three.
It kind of makes it look like a clown outfit.
I don't mind it.
I don't mind it so much.
I wonder if I can even put one here.
I mean, I was trying to put two, but I think I lost one.
I don't know where it went.
I feel like we maybe don't need it.
What do you guys think?
A circus of value.
It's cute.
I wish they were just a little bit smaller.
That's okay.
We don't need to have the buttons there.
That's fine.
actually yeah it's fine it doesn't really make sense it's
okay I kind of had to squish everything a little bit so and
the hair well I will actually be making those actual ribbons
I do have blue fabric I just was lazy for these guys because
they're so tiny man thank you speaking of snake I'm coming
back from Federal Hall I even met another Ibu I forgot my
plushie at home so I hope I hope it's okay to use mint
quackdom.
Hashtag minto2go.
And yes, it was still under construction.
No way!
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it's still under construction.
If I had a blue pen.
I do!
Wait, hold on.
I have to show you guys, I have to show you guys.
If I can get it out, I'm not gonna...
I have a few notepads for when I like oh I found the other
oh no this is the first one never mind um I have a few
notepads for like when I give gifts to people I write like
small notes or whatever and I have this perfect shade of
blue pen that I could use for it but um the first one I'll
show you the first one because the second one's my favorite
the first one our lemon
lemons like that and that yeah so i have some lemon paper i
think it's only those two designs but yeah it's very cute oh
yeah two design lemon lemon lemon and then the second one
that i have but i um is a bit bigger are the zoom bill this
one is this one's a little tough i feel like it's more for
like a origami or something here to ride on right but they
have other writable ones like this one is so cute and then
this one is so cute so yeah i have these two designs that i
use for uh for writing like little notes thank you notes and
things like that
They look so clean too.
I take good care of my stuff.
But I've only been able to use it a handful of times.
Maybe I will hide a little note inside.
I'll write something out for whoever gets this puppet.
Just a little like, thanks for getting it.
Thanks for supporting charity.
But Ash, what else could I use it on?
Off Kai, I'll hide like little notes around or something.
Or, um, at like a Satsuna booth.
Okie dokie, let's draw these.
Yay!
Um, next is what?
Uh.
I'm looking at myself.
Egotistical woman.
Let's do the
ribbon.
Maybe.
Yes.
Actually, I'm looking at this now and I'm like, maybe I
shouldn't have put it there.
But it's fine.
It's fine.
It's not completely accurate.
Let's do the ribbon here.
And then we'll put on my googly eyes.
And then I think I'll be done with Minto for...
Oh, the white here.
I just need to cut some strips.
Some small strips.
It's a little mishy.
The felt, they kind of disintegrate.
Those are ruffles.
Obviously.
Duh.
I'm just gonna leave it like that for now until I make the
back.
And, uh...
Here, I'll show you.
See?
Let's do the other side.
Nice.
Alright.
Up here.
like so
this one actually I might have to glue down up here glue
down here
one thing that's hard about this glue gun is I can't really
tell when it like when the glue goes you know what I mean
It's kind of, it's got very loose handle.
Okay.
All right, now the ribbon.
Neck ribbon!
Ah, your Zendaminto is done for now.
For stream.
Small boy.
Yeah, pull my loose trigger.
Wait, where did my Sharpie go?
I do actually need that.
I'm losing everything.
I'm losing everything, I'm losing my mind.
Where, is it under my butt again?
It might be.
If it is.
So it didn't drop.
It's hidden amongst.
It is, uh...
Do you see the Sharpie?
Where?
It's on my head.
Wait, what the heck?
Wait, actually, where is it?
Uh...
I lost it.
There!
I actually don't see it.
And it's gone.
Oh my gosh, shy.
Wait, what the heck?
Actually...
Where is it?
I'm looking in all the places it could have...
I see it!
It did fail!
It did fall!
It fell, it fell, it fell!
Retrieved!
Okay, now we draw the shape a little bit Wait, like this,
like this.
Like that.
Oh, George.
George hasn't been three hours yet?
In three hours.
I'll marry you.
Headed to the airport in a few and I'm a little nervous, but
if there aren't any issues with the standy, we'll be
international!
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Good luck, Paige!
Have a safe flight!
Have so much fun.
What if George comes back a ghost?
Angry ghost.
Like you didn't sing for me.
Now you must marry me.
Oh, George, no, please.
I'm just a humble ghost.
Please.
Little town of little people.
Every day, like the one before.
He's like he's the beast.
I'm Belle.
Little town.
It's a quiet village.
Waking up to say...
Oh, that means I have to be French.
Bonjour!
Bonjour, bonjour, bonjour, bonjour!
There goes the baker.
Oh, I think I made that one too long.
I call waste the same old bread and rolls to sell.
Every morning's just the same as the morning that we came to
this poor provincial town.
Good morning, Belle.
Good enough.
Yeah!
Oh, hold on.
Let's clean it up.
I just read the most wonderful book.
Oh, no, I'm ruining it.
I'm ruining it.
Lock in.
Lock in, gamer.
Lock in, streamer.
That's my streamer.
She locks in.
Ah, I think I messed it up too much.
I think I cut off a little too much from the top.
Ah, the side looks so good even.
Disaster.
Disaster has struck.
Oh.
It would look so good otherwise.
Hold on.
Maybe I can fix it.
It might just be a little bit skinny.
Everything else is asymmetrical.
Why can't this be?
No.
I don't think they're saving it.
Maybe I should use smaller scissors for this part.
It's so small.
Let's try again.
This can be a backup.
Where's my brain?
I'm good.
So small.
It's tough.
Okay.
Let me grab a pair of smaller scissors real quick.
Actually, I have to open them.
Well, they're not that much smaller.
Oh, I look at them.
But...
Maybe it's okay.
Pee!
It's pink!
The pink is real.
She did it!
Oh, Jumbo does it again!
Okay, so far so good.
I have a better feeling about this one.
What color is it?
Alright, go, thank you.
Thanks for the pink.
If I come back as a ghost, I'll have to get in line, buddy.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I'm only 19.
Forever.
I don't think I'm ready for marriage.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of commitment.
You understand.
Rainbow time.
Rainbow.
Nah, just pink.
Uh-oh.
I'm doing it again.
Okay, wait.
It's salvaged.
We're fine.
It's okay.
Nothing is...
Everything's fine for now.
I think the easiest one will be Phoebe She just wears a
dress And like pink Wings for her For her fairyness And It's
gonna be It's gonna be We just do like the flower I was just
gonna do like the pom-poms for flowers and stuff Making a
mess I'm making a real mess here
It looks so good There's a little on this side that I want
to get.
It's a tiny bit, tad.
I'm being a perfectionist once again.
I'm sorry.
We're done.
Put it down.
Put the scissors down.
It's like a baking show.
Stop.
Stop touching your thing.
Yay!
Yeah, yeah.
I'll even move it down just a little bit.
Time's up.
What if we just watch the movie On the opposite Ends of the
jowl Oh, no?
Yeah!
I ball time.
I'm scared of drawing the mouth.
What if I mess it up, you know?
It's permanent.
It's permanent marker, you guys.
What if I just start doing the mouth first?
because if I mess it up then I could just scrap the entire
thing if we mess up the mouth here it's game over it's
really game over if I mess it up let's practice let's
practice
you're a suit not pirate oh World War 5, sing Overdrive by
Iosis or I will literally explode.
Oh overdrive, oh overdrive, oh overdrive, oh overdrive, oh
overdrive, oh overdrive, oh overdrive, oh overdrive, oh
overdrive, oh overdrive, oh overdrive, oh overdrive, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh song wait i'm not
saying you overdrive anymore wait wait wait they laugh wait
hold on wait wait it stops wait how does the rest of
wait i was gonna do hold on Sorry.
It just kind of looks like a...
This kind of mouth.
Like a...
Which might be fine.
Morphed in Dumbari Show is still the precious thing.
Hey, Mito!
Oh, heyo!
What do you do?
Do you have a pencil?
I don't think it's...
Wait, I need to listen to Overdrive real quick now.
I know she laughs.
She's like, ah.
Wait, I need to listen to Overdrive now.
But sorry, I won't let you guys listen to it because I don't
want...
I don't want...
YouTube to get mad at me.
Overdrive.
Oh, Overdrive.
She's laughing.
fun oh overdrive overdrive oh oh oh oh yeah
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
And then she's mad.
And then in the middle.
And then they turn around.
Oh, gosh.
I can't remember this part.
Oh, then they put in the...
You know.
The...
Water reminds me of like hold on wait That reminds
me of like, hold on, wait.
Hold on.
Oh, wait, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Back to YouTube.
Wait.
Don't play Overdrive again.
Here we go.
Is this it?
What?
Da, da, da, da, da.
Nerissa did a tweet about this and it like i was like oh my
gosh
sensei dance juice dance juice don't let's say i'm like So,
so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, don't do, don't,
don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't,
don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, I
wonder if I could play this.
Wait a minute.
There's like a whole dance for it for that dance.
Oh my goodness.
Okay, sorry.
Back to.
Back to everything now.
There's so much we miss out when we can't see our hands.
I know.
I'm always dancing.
Okay, I
think like that is the way.
Think like that is the way.
I'm getting all the fuzz off of the Sharpie first.
Wait, hold on, my chat froze.
Sharpie.
Yeah!
Hold on.
I think I can do this one too.
This part.
I have to cut the pipe cleaner in my lap though.
Sorry.
We're fine.
Everything's okay.
How did I cut the pipe cleaner?
with my scissors.
Just with them scissors.
Nothing fancy to see here.
Oh!
Alright.
Oop.
The hair is starting to come off the pipe loom.
And for now, the eyes are that's okay.
For now, Minto is complete.
Hey guys, my name's Mim Phantom.
It's nice to meet you.
And I just was born today.
Happy birthday to me.
Thanks for joining.
No, we're not done yet.
We're not done yet.
Time for Phoebe.
Let me clean up a little bit.
Everything else will be for when I complete the back side of
Minto.
And do like my hair and stuff like that.
Awesome!
Yeah!
Good job team!
We did it, we did it.
It only took three hours for one puppet.
By that logic, I'll be done in nine hours.
Is
it possible to possess the doll and fly around?
It would be kind of awkward because, well, like...
Oh, I guess I wouldn't...
If I'm flying around...
Well, I can't, like, fly with it.
You know what I mean?
Like, I would...
I would just be, like, shaken on the...
on the table.
All right, Phoebe.
I need you guys' opinion.
Because for Phoebe, her dress...
We got pink.
We got her skin.
Her dress is quite kind of...
It's like olive-y, but not.
I was like, do I go for the more vibrant green or do I go
for the olive-y color?
I think I might go for the more vibrant.
Because also with Vicky, I couldn't get like a good hair
color for her, so I had to go with yellow.
In real life, it's very yellow.
So I'm thinking maybe the vibrant colors are the way to go.
Okay.
Iboot 8008-135 pushed me.
Sorry, that guy has immunity to everything.
I cannot help you.
But yeah, I got all of Vicky's colors here.
like a good dark blue so she had to be like kind of a
brighter blue can
i eat taco bell before before we start baby
oh let me get me off the screen there we go
what i'll do is uh let me i'll i'll do the hand first and
then i will trace it out and then i'll go eat okay i have to
remember to leave Extra room.
Down here.
Yay!
Only if you get Baja Blast as your drink.
I cannot have soda!
What do you want me to do?
I don't even know what Coca-Cola tastes like.
I don't know what the Baja Blast tastes like.
I don't know what Mountain Dew tastes like.
I don't know...
I don't know Sprite tastes like.
I don't know anything!
I'm gonna go get my food.
I'll be right back.
Taco Bell.
Yeah.
Yay!
Taco Bell!
Taco Bell.
It's just been...
Wait, that's my dinner.
I got it before stream.
This is a regular taco.
Hmm.
Let's see how they did.
With my taco.
Looks like a taco to me.
What if you let the soda go flat first?
I've tried that before.
It's not particularly delicious.
No, not the taco, but the soda.
Mint, will everyone get their own puppet once they're done?
Like, will Phoebe get her puppet and will Vicky get her
puppet?
Because, um...
Actually, these are going for...
They're being auctioned for charity.
Why can't you have soda?
Sorry if you've answered before.
No, it's okay.
Um, I can't have it because it like messes with my tomtom.
Yeah.
I also have a five layer.
But maybe...
I'll wait on that.
I'm just so hungry right now.
Fragile ghost tummy.
Yeah, I throw up my ectoplasm everywhere.
Can you try telling your tummy to lock the F in?
I know, right?
Didn't work.
Can you drink kombucha?
I've never tried it before.
Is it...
What is a kombucha?
It's lightly fizzy.
It's technically mold tea.
Like, I hear that it's good for you.
But how is fermented tea good for you?
Wait, I'm just...
Hmm?
Whoa!
Holy cow, look at all that shower queen.
It just all came out.
I've been trying to eat apple cider vinegar gummies lately I
think the only way I can eat apple cider vinegar is with
like a pill because I'm too weak to the vinegar I think the
gummies are so disgusting too it's apple cider vinegar is
the worst ever yeah you'll eat a lemon straight up because
it's delicious I
a what?
A cream-based play?
What does that mean?
Yeah, lemons are awesome and delicious, and vinegar is
nasty.
Also, yeah, how can you compare lemons to apple cider
vinegar?
There's like apples to apple cider vinegar.
Hold on.
I have tissue.
Both are That doesn't mean anything.
Both sour equals both the same.
I don't even consider vinegar sour.
Like, the smell alone just, like, makes me want to...
You know, maybe it's a thing.
You know how some people can't have cilantro?
Maybe I'm special.
I can't have vinegar.
You know, maybe I'm just like...
Yeah, I got the soap chain.
I'm allergic to chocolate, but I've never heard of
carbonation upsetting someone's stomach.
Pormento Tommy.
Yeah, I've never heard of someone allergic to chocolate.
Remember I could get Taco Bell 3 Crispy Taco combo for less
than this super chat.
Stop.
Don't talk about it.
You're going to depress me.
I'm depressed.
Look at this bad boy, though.
Beefy burrito, baby.
There's five whole layers in this guy right now.
Five of them.
There's five layers.
Where's the Crunchwrap?
Well, I wanted a taco and I wanted a five layer separate.
If I wanted them together, then I would get the Crunchwrap
Supreme.
Crunchwrap Supreme.
Five whole layers.
Wait, should I prove it?
Wait, how many?
Okay, wait.
Bean.
Beef.
Sour cream.
Cheese.
Bean beef.
Sour cream.
What's the last one?
What's the last layer?
I'm allergic to penicillin.
Since we're just airing out our weakness.
Tortilla!
Oh, rice?
No, there's no rice.
I'm going to have just a bite.
It looks pale.
Wait, it looks...
Hello?
Why is it so...
Two layers.
I don't think they toasted this tortilla.
all three I got the cheese oh bean bean bean four four we've
infiltrated four layers we've infiltrated four layers oh you
got to ask for it grill no way really ask for a refund for
the missing layers I've only gotten four layers.
No, I can see sour cream in there.
There's definitely the fifth layer.
I'll have that bad boy later, though.
I will have that bad boy later.
For now, we're back to puppets, everybody.
Back to puppeting.
I'm allergic to cute girls, so I died the first time I saw
Minstream.
Being a ghost isn't too bad, though.
What are you talking about?
I always say not to become a ghost.
You're not a ghost, Nick.
Don't lie.
Don't lie to me.
If you're a ghost, what's the seventh rule?
Mmm.
Exactly.
I'm never gonna say it.
I'm never gonna say it XO, XO gossip girl
I'm not saying it because it's not meant for human ears
You'll know when Well, I hope you don't become ghosts I hope
you live happy lives Happy and fulfilled lives So that you
don't feel regret To become a ghost You know want you to I
want you to go elsewhere trick question one doesn't speak of
the seventh rule unless there is that one exception and
that's if a certified batty asks you what the seventh rule
is so much money for the forbidden oh wait how much money
for the forbidden ghost knowledge now you can't You can't
pay me.
You can't pay me.
You'd best not talk about it.
First rule, the seventh rule.
Don't talk about the seventh rule.
Do you know a certified batty?
You're looking at him.
Cheeks and all.
You rub the booty for good luck.
Meow.
Won't you stop?
No, Radden.
I'll never stop.
Now, turn your...
Stick your sweet ass back up in the air.
Oh, okay.
Um, I don't know what came over me.
Sorry.
Let's...
Puppet.
I really can't mess this one up because otherwise I didn't
get any extra for Phoebe.
And also I used my extra.
I can't mess up on Vicky's either.
I don't have another extra extra.
For her as well.
Like the one scoop.
It's all or nothing.
I don't know why but I see the screaming Ash baby.
No I get it.
I see him too.
He's like.
Just the emotion you carry into battle.
Lust!
Oh, damn, me, though.
Do you know what day it is today?
That emoji is...
Or that...
Not emoji.
That, like, what's that guy's face?
There's an emo for him on YouTube?
Like that.
Oh, my gosh.
I haven't seen that, I think, in, like, 500 years.
I don't know.
Time is a mystery.
What is that guy called?
The epic face?
Epic man?
Epic face?
Why do they have that on here?
You don't know what came over you?
This is perfectly adorable for you.
I thought it was a lol face.
Epic awesome face.
Oh my gosh, it's so epic!
Wow, seeing it is kind of insane.
It reminds me of such a simpler time.
Wow.
I'm like, whoa.
Remember when late epic, epic face.
It was around the same time as the troll face, right?
I can't remember.
And then you had the memes that were like, hold on, hold on.
Hold on.
Let me do this real quick.
before I forget.
Turn it inside out.
Nice.
Oh, you can't even see the Sharpie.
Oh, so good.
Yeah, baby.
Yeah.
Um, I'm gonna draw it out for you guys.
These, these memes.
And then this is like all dark.
This is all.
You know all.
Like this.
when did we lose like having meme formats like this the
demotivational is that what it was called
is that a demotivational poster we lost the craft like now
memes nowadays i feel like are so random
it's like when you see people being like oh why don't we do
disney like this anymore it's like they'll be like we can't
this is this is what it feels like we can't we can't do it
anymore we don't know how everybody who knew how to die oh
really wait i'm gonna draw the oh really owl from memory
Oh, really, ow.
This is, like, a really cursed little scrap.
Holy cow, it's just...
It's a...
I throw it in the trash.
Alright, let's...
Glue.
Let's get glue.
You know what was also random?
Ladder goat.
I don't know that one.
Ladder goat?
I've never heard.
I don't think I've heard that.
Save it!
Here, I'll cut it.
I'll give it to Steiner.
He'll do something with it.
Say, put this at the booth.
Auction this one off, but the money goes to me.
don't don't auction it won't be auctioned i don't know
what's gonna happen to it i'll tell him to do something with
it wait am i cutting the owl oh no
don't say anything just hand it to him oh no here i'll write
it down here i'll write it down at the bottom let's just
realize afterwards
uh here it's like the pack opener I do cut the cards!
Oh, really?
There we go.
Mim.
I'll save this for somebody.
Or, like I said, I'll give it the styler.
Okay, now I'm actually going back to...
You guys, I have two other...
I have two other puppets to finish, please.
Stop distracting me.
Stop distracting me!
Weird to think we're closer to 2030 than 2020 now.
Yeah!
You're right.
I think this all started when I was asked to sing Overdrive.
It activated my brain.
I'm gonna cut this into this a little bit.
little bit more.
A little like that.
There we go.
2030?
Guys, I don't feel so good.
I, for one, am excited about things that happen in the
future, though.
Like, I don't know.
I feel maybe it just I, you know.
Den Setsu's been doing so many cool things.
lately that it makes me excited what else will happen and
you know what other you know things will happen events and
things like that and more times that I get to meet you guys
more you know when I get to see you guys again those things
excite me so I'm gonna see you in San Jose I'll see you
there!
100 years have been to Naibu's!
Naibu's are meant to 100 years!
Tensetsu da Iexu is a good reason to be excited for the
future!
I'm really excited for a song coming out.
I think the lyrics are so fun.
I think the song is so fun.
I can't wait to share with you guys.
And then other stuff we're working on.
um is really craziness so I can't wait to talk about that
and share that with you guys unless you're dead in three
hours like George I can't do anything about that though
sorry I forgot to submit my chance no it's okay though it's
okay Okay, um...
Honestly...
Hopefully you can hear them well.
I think you might, but...
Yippee!
Let's see.
Should it looks good?
Should it be good?
Oh!
One here.
But mostly good, it seems.
Nice.
George.
Okay.
Very nice.
It looks like a gingerbread man.
Wait.
Oh, I love gingerbread.
Well, it's really nice to reminisce on the past.
I'm really glad Min Token looked forward to the future.
Be excited about new things too.
Denso's future is looking bright.
Gingerbread.
I need
like a close-up oh wait I have this picture saved I'm an
idiot I could just look at it's so small on my screen okay
there we go okay good okay does he know the muffin man do
you know the muffin man the muffin man the muffin man I
think I know the muffin man who lives on Pillsbury Lane
Well, she's married to the muffin man.
The muffin man?
The muffin man!
Oh, Drury Lane!
Wait, I thought it was Pillsbury Lane because it's like,
uh...
I thought it was Pillsbury Lane because they make biscuits.
What the hell is a Drury?
Not the gumdrop button!
Don't think Pillsbury existed yet.
Oh.
Childhood marketing successful.
Oh, man.
My bad.
Phoebe.
Oh, I do need some white.
Actually, her collar is like kind of...
It's like...
Am I crazy?
No, it's white.
It's not off white.
Is this...
Is her collar...
collar off white or is it white I think it's white
I think it's white I think I'm going crazy
ignore me
oh I've grabbed blue what's wrong with me okay white we'll
do um collar just
white white than off I think it's my monitor maybe because
on my other monitor it on this monitor it looks white right
and on this monitor it looks off white which is very strange
because they are the same monitor how is that possible why
are they doing that
white balance is hard so true could be a shadow as well well
maybe
hidden ghost hidden
ghost I'm always with you Phoebe I'm always with you I'm
always with you Phoebe we can use this even as though look
at how look at I'm so resourceful I take a piece and I use
it again
Alright.
Let's trim it down a little bit.
Trim it down a little bit.
Okay.
And probably for that middle bit, we're going to use a
pom-pom.
Actually, I'm going to take out every single pink pom-pom
for Phoebe.
Oh, that's orange.
Don't look at it.
Okay.
I'm not colorblind.
I just grabbed the wrong thing.
There was another one right at the top.
And I accidentally grabbed...
I'm not colorblind.
I grabbed...
I grabbed the orange instead of the pink.
Just like now.
Oh, gosh.
Wait, they're all spilling everywhere.
Keep singing to the PCM!
I have to, like, concentrate to...
Remember the words.
And then I'm, like, trying to do other stuff.
Oh, wait.
I think I found another pink.
Yes.
Oh wait!
I forgot.
Maybe I should do some pink on my cheeks.
Or it's cheeks.
These aren't silly.
Wait, but then I think I won't have enough for Phoebe's
hair.
For the flowers in her.
I want us to all have pink.
Blush.
Maybe I could get like a pink marker and do it instead.
Because these are more like 3D.
So they should be for her flowers, I think.
I don't think there's any more.
Oh, wait, I see another one.
Alright, so we got five.
I'm dumping them out on my table.
That's it.
Five!
We have five.
I got five on it.
Ah, man.
Okay.
That's alright.
That's fine.
Uh, five whole pom-poms.
What do we do?
I dropped them everywhere.
I feel- maybe I have another pen, like the pink one.
Or like the blue one.
So do pink.
I'll try.
I'll look for it.
Cut them in half.
I think it'll be too messy.
It's fine.
I'd rather use them for the flowers in her hair.
Actually, she has like almost like five.
She has like six flowers.
So five pom-poms works, actually.
Okay, let me...
Let's just trace this.
Chubby.
The lapel looks like a fang.
Kinda.
Oh gosh.
Eh.
Please.
Okay.
As long as they're somewhat even looking.
Oh no!
It's fine.
As long as they're somewhat even looking.
It doesn't matter.
Who cares about charity?
Who cares about it looking good for charity?
I don't.
Whatever.
Yay!
Oh wait, I was gonna use a pom-pom for the middle.
Like that.
I think I have to do that.
Yay!
Are you a fan of Phoebe?
Of course I am.
Of course I am!
How to do her dress?
now.
It's so like...
Also, when did I draw on here?
Oh, where's that fudge?
Maybe it was fudge.
My hands are again becoming all like, look at the... my
finger.
Um, alright.
So we have these done.
Let's grab the green.
The green, the green!
It's so...
It's actually quite a dark...
Oh wait, this is the wrong green.
I just realize this is a dark green this is the green we
need okay that was scary okay let's move this guy back over
here get him out of the way all right we just need this to
kind of we just this is gonna look super tinkerbell i talked
about tinkerbell earlier this is gonna be the most
tinkerbell it's like a down Down.
She is a fairy.
And she was a fairy.
It looks maybe a little silly, but that's okay.
We have more green.
I actually have quite a bit of green, so...
It kind of looks ungabunga.
Like a cave...
Like...
Babies first.
Leaf covering the privates.
But surely, with everything else, it will look like Phoebe.
Phoebe's new outfit, caveman.
Sorry for leaking.
And then we also have to put white underneath.
That might help.
Actually, that might help.
Let's just do that first.
Because all...
Also, there's like a little bit under here that like is like
a ruffle-y bit that we'll have.
You know what I mean?
So it won't be complete.
It won't be complete.
Yes.
It's just gonna have to do with how like the we did the
outfit.
You know what I mean?
Just because I can't do ruffles.
I can't do ruffles in here.
the pleats and stuff like that.
It's just how it's got to be.
Love the balls by Ryden.
Alright.
This part, I don't want any uh, sharpie.
Sorry.
You can't see me cutting it.
Okay.
Something like that.
Wait.
Let's just wait, right?
Yeah.
Wait.
Orange sugar.
Let's do this.
Trim this down a lot.
We can even, like, do this.
Okay.
George, look at that.
Everybody loves you.
Everybody loves you, George.
That's so sweet.
How are we feeling about it, guys?
Are you guys seeing Phoebe?
Are you guys seeing Phoebe yet?
You're not seeing...
It actually looks so tinkerbell at the moment.
See the vision.
It's coming together.
Ginger Phoebe.
Gingerbread Phoebe.
It's very fairy.
I think the hair will...
Yeah.
I think the hair...
will be what does it.
Right now, I think you can see the dress and be like, oh,
yeah, yeah, that's VB.
Maybe if I add the gloves as well, but I can't do sheer, you
know?
So it's kind of, they're just going to look like super
harsh.
It's going to end up looking kind of Sailor Moon.
Hmm.
Gonna end up looking like Sailor Moon more than anything
else.
Let's see.
And
then I can also do her let's see her neck ribbon with like
some pipe cleaner oh
it looks so sailor moon with some pipe cleaner I do want to
do her arm her arm badge hmm
It's not a bad thing that it looks very Sailor Moon.
It's just kind of funny to me.
We lost her.
Like so?
Pretzel!
Wow.
Pretzel.
A kettle.
A pretzel.
Nice.
Something like that.
okay
let's just glue this stuff for now um let me start working
on her arm
i think i can probably just wing these i get it because
she's got she's a fairy she's got wings i'm winging it okay
and then this one is
like so
They're like pointed on one bottom and regular They're like
roughly on the top Oh, they're huge They're so big They're
humongous We'll do the roughly side Let's cut it down like
to here
Like that
A little shorter, a little shorter I think Just a tiny bit
shorter
Oops Not my cleanest ruffle But it'll have to do Maybe I
wonder what I can do To add more details to it You know Hmm
She has so many details that I like can't do You know like
for me I felt like I had a lot of details But they were more
Phoebe has teeny tiny little little details that like just
crazy.
What charity is this for?
It's for the...
There's a charity auction at Faname.
It's for the Make-A-Wish in the Greater Bay Area.
Yeah.
Oh, Raiders.
Oh, hi!
Sorry, I didn't notice.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, I see you too!
Thank you for the gift and thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
We're currently making Phoebe!
I'm gonna make this prettier looking.
I can't say it.
Paper axe!
Thank you!
Yum yum!
Oh, sorry.
Mr. Yum yum.
Thank you!
Where's the glitch face?
Face off!
Thank you!
Darko!
Thank you all, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
And honestly, it's okay if it's shorter because it's just
for the arms.
Oh, that looks already better, I think.
Yeah, yeah!
Like that.
Yeah!
We could do, use the scrapboard as well.
Woo-pa!
Thank you so much for the food!
Thank you!
Holy cow!
That's thank you!
Borrowed children!
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you all so much!
We're the gift!
Thank you!
I appreciate you all so much!
Bring scissors.
What I might do is maybe go back over Phoebe's...
Oops.
Okay.
Phoebe's with a pen.
And like get some smaller details in, you know?
That's what I might try doing.
Oops.
I think I...
Uh.
It works.
It's fine.
Oh my gosh.
My tea!
Thank you!
For the video.
What the heck?
My chat is just so-and-so has received a gift.
So-and-so has received a gift.
Like, there's nobody even chatting.
It's just all so-and-so receiving gifts thank you guys thank
you what the heck thank you thank you so very much
it's not perfect I wish I could have done another little
spiky what
do you guys think
you could make Maybe if an angle, one more spike tiny.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, Garfunkel!
Thank you so much.
Thank you for the...
Thank you.
What's happening?
What's going on?
Haruki, thank you.
Bega!
I'm a girl.
Thank you.
They almost look like the crowns from...
Um, where the wild things are.
Triangle Down, thank you.
I thank you for the 20 gift.
What is it?
Why, I'm gonna beat you guys up.
I'm gonna beat you guys up.
Stop sending gift of memberships!
Talk to me!
Stop!
My chat's full of gift of memberships!
I give up.
Stop!
First off, thank you.
CZ, thank you!
Phantom Knight, thank you!
Blue eyes under, thank you.
T-cup, thank you.
How can I use this?
Stop!
Guys, I have to do that!
I have to do puppets!
Holy cow!
Oh my gosh.
Nexy, thank you.
Packed up, thank you.
Eggerman, thank you.
Bloodless, thank you.
Look at egg, thank you for the campaign.
K-0100, thank you.
Hell's a horn, thank you.
Goggles, thank you.
Rice, thank you.
DPSA, we'll try to thank you.
Of wild, not gift and membership the tips.
Organizer, thank you.
Lads, thank you.
Spike, thank you.
Okay.
No, this is it.
This is it.
We're done.
Thank you.
Why are you gifting more?
Oh my gosh.
Evergreen.
Oh, thank you.
Why is it so much?
Thank you.
Okay, sir, thank you.
Holy cow.
Good, our goal, thank you.
Mario, thank you.
Oh my gosh.
That was my birthday last, birthday last week.
I didn't get to catch a stream live until now.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
Thank you so much for the hug.
Because Raiders, yo!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
Okay, turtle, thank you!
No more.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
We've reached...
Everybody, everybody is now...
There is, there is, there is, there are, everybody in the
world is now a member you may not send anymore.
It's impossible.
I will draw Phoebe's hair.
Where's the brown?
Here.
Brown.
Okay.
Back to...
Back to draw.
Alright.
Hmm.
So much green.
Green, green, green.
Green, green.
Everything is green.
Everything is green!
Alright, let me stick this on her head.
Do the same thing that I did before.
Or I did the top of my head.
Sad.
Perfect.
Oh my gosh, it's so hard to see.
I don't know how to do her braid yet.
I've been wondering about that.
I think what I'll do too is do Phoebe's like half, like she
has like a little twin tail.
I think I'll do that version.
It'll be easier if we're making the, uh, the, uh, what's it
called, too?
Oh my Oh my gosh!
Midai!
Thank you!
Cut three thin strips of fabric and braid them.
Oh, I could!
I could, I could.
I thought about doing that with like some of the pink too.
Okay, I'll do that.
Okay.
I'll do... What I'll do for now is I'll just like kind of...
Oops.
I think I did too far.
That's okay.
that's alright okay all right let's cut and hope I'm
going back to making the puppets you guys we I haven't even
started on Vicki please it's been four and a half hours I
only have one time maybe I should have done Phoebe first she
was she's arguably the easiest all
right I'm concentrating I'm concentrating have a great day
thank you too You too.
It's so hard to see the color.
Like the way it tracing.
Let's see if...
I didn't finish this, but let's try.
And...
Another little...
Okay, like that.
Phoebe hair!
3, 2, 1!
Phoebe!
Oh!
That's not bad!
That's not bad at all!
Yeah, it's a little dark.
I wish I could have made it lighter, but...
Phoebe!
And then...
Let's do her side pony.
Oh, ah, ah, ah, wait today.
Invisible boost, thank you!
Thank you!
Oh, scroll in and see it.
I was like, wait a second.
I think I missed a one.
I've been gone for four hours and I only missed one.
No, I'm working on two.
I'm working on two.
Two is literally happening right now.
Hold.
Yeah, hold.
Two is it.
Literally.
Literally being worked on at this very moment.
I feel though.
I feel Phoebe is I'm worried about Vicky I have to
finish these for Japan I guess I could sit in my hotel room
and do them as well but I don't want to Matthew Thank you
Thank you
Vicky's head will come off What am I, a magician?
Vicky's head will be stable.
No, I'll finish them.
I'll finish them.
I don't know about tonight, but they will definitely be
done.
I always under or overestimate how long they take, you know?
I'm always just like, yeah, make it poppies, la la la.
And then my, you know, my, my, oh, but, I gotta add this
little detail.
Oh, I just gotta...
I gotta add this.
I gotta add this part, you know?
That kicks in.
And it turns into...
Oops.
I realized I...
Did not quite do this right.
Like so!
Velcro tape for Vicky's head.
Yeah, my perfectionism is too strong.
But then, once we have this, add some of these little
bobbles, like that?
Wait, I'm missing one.
I had five.
Where's the last one go?
Uh-oh.
Where did the last one go?
Maybe it escaped amongst all the chaos.
want to do um i want to do like little leaves for phoebe
like in her hair and stuff so i'm gonna just cut those out
real quick phoebe's already looking super cute thank you
yeah oops oops i forgot it's not glued down
all right Sorry, I am cutting the leaves in my lap, so...
I'm just gonna do like a couple...
Just a couple leaves.
War of the Freibree.
Chanchibree.
Phoebe.
Chanchibee.
Snake, is that you?
Oh!
I forgot also.
life.
Ocelot developed a crush on Raiden.
Raiden saved him from his hiccups and he fell in love with
him.
Love at first sight.
Okay, just one more.
How many do I...
I think I have two on this?
Oh.
One on this... I'll have two on this side and three on that
side.
He likes the pretty boys.
I don't...
Ocelot doesn't like pretty boys.
Ocelot loves a rugged man.
Tomodachi life has changed him.
It's the cat bedroom.
It's changed him.
I still...
We're missing one pom-pom.
I'm nervous.
I have all this pink for Phoebe as well.
I'm gonna cut the strands now for the...
Because one thing I want to do is like, have it layered like
the pink on top, you know?
For her... for these parts.
Sorry, I have one BGM.
Once we have more... Once Denzitsu has more songs, I will be
able to put on other music for these streams.
But for now, we only got one song.
It is nice though, right?
I think so too.
Oh, let me give her some googly eyes.
What kind of mouth should we do for Phoebe?
Maybe just like a cute little smile, regular smile.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
Phoebe is getting close to becoming Chan Chibi.
Let's start gluing.
baby.
I'm feeling good.
And then this we gotta do and this we have to do.
I just I just balded her.
I balded her.
I I balded her.
Bald, bald, bald.
No hair for Phoebe.
She is bald.
Just like you all will be one day.
We'll all go bald.
Let's go bald together.
3, 2, 1.
You first?
Don't say things.
that you might regret.
If I go first, that means you must go second, which means
you are signing the verbal contract of us going bald
together.
I'm already bald.
You are already bald!
I know this.
I have your passport photo.
I don't Sorry if that scares you I don't want to say
something And someone be like Do you actually I'm actually
really scared about that
I'm going to report this YouTuber We're hacking Oh my god
though You know what's so crazy is There was one time I So
basically On a couple Japan trips ago which is such a crazy
absolute bonkers statement to say but anyway I went to I
went to a Rio con in Osaka a Rio con if you will I went to a
Rio con in Osaka and and I was like you know what I don't
want to bring all of my stuff on the on the bullet train on
the Shinkansen I'm just going to you No, I already had a
hotel for my entire stay.
Okay, Nancy.
I already had a hotel for my stay, so I packed a small bag.
I packed a small bag and then left most of my stuff at my
hotel in Tokyo.
Nanashi-san.
And so what I didn't, what I realized, But I forgot though,
was I had left my passport in the hotel as well.
And one thing that if you don't, if you don't know this, if
you're traveling to Japan and you're getting a hotel, they,
I don't know, I don't remember if other countries do this, I
can't remember.
But they want to, they want your passport for, and like it's
not your, like they want your passport.
They want your, they don't, like your driver's license is
not enough.
You need your passport so that they can like, I don't know,
they take a picture of it or something.
And so I didn't have it.
And I was like, oh my God, I'm in Osaka.
I won't be able to check in into any, like, hotel.
Like, regardless, like, say it, like, the real con says no.
I won't be able to check into any hotel in Osaka.
I would have to go all the way back to Tokyo.
And so I was like, oh my gosh, what do I do?
What do I do?
And they were like, do you?
Do you have any way?
Oh, also, before I forget, let me add her mole on her neck.
Right here.
They were like, they were going to, they were like, at first
they were like, do you have anybody at home that could give
you, that could send like a picture of your passport?
And I was like, I don't.
And then they were like, we're going to call your current
hotel and ask them to go into your room and search your
things and find your passport and take a picture of it for
us.
And I was like, I don't like that idea either.
I really don't like that idea either.
So one thing that I did is I was searching through all of my
photos.
I was like, I have to have had a saved photo of my passport
somewhere.
And I was checking my Google Drive.
I was checking everywhere.
I have a galaxy.
And I was like, what if I search passport in the photos
thing?
Like, you can search, like, they have, you know, they have
like their whatever detection that can tell what a picture
is, you know?
Yeah, the smart search.
I searched passport.
And that's how I somehow had a photo saved somewhere.
and it's and it saved me oh i was like this is the one time
i'm like you know what sure be able to scan my stuff it was
oh my gosh still terrifying it was a horrible feeling i was
like sitting in the lobby like and i felt bad because like
you know i had gone with friends And I was like, everybody
is like, just kind of like, oh, we're not going to stay
without you.
And I was like, no, no, you guys are going to stay without
me.
But like, oh, I felt, it was such a horrible feeling.
So, don't, if that ever happens to you, maybe try searching
for it in your phone.
That's how AI should be used.
Agreed.
Agreed!
That saved my booty.
The other one is this one.
Alright, let me just...
It was a scary moment.
I carry my passport at all times in a pickpocket safe pouch.
I actually, like, never carried mine with me.
Which is not good advice.
I think streamlines are being a little slow, but thank you
for the fun streams.
Last few weeks, Minto.
Really nice way to distress from work.
Thank you, Capadro.
I think it's completely...
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
Thank you for the...
Akadono.
Yeah, I think it's completely bogged down by all the gifted
memberships.
Haven't been able to be as active recently.
I'm glad I got to see you do some arts and crafts with us.
Love you, Minto.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Roku Nana, thank you.
Roku Nana.
And Phil!
Thank you!
I don't even know if these will show up within the stream
time, so.
I mean, though this past year, watching and cheering you on
has been amazing and genuinely one of the happier years of
my life.
Thank you to your best inventory.
Little points is so inspiring!
Thank you for creating a community of such cute iBoys.
You guys are all the cutest ever!
You guys, I love iBoys.
iBoys are the cutest ever!
I'll always keep doing my best.
I'll always keep trying.
Alright, now let's cut out these hairs.
What's nice about this is it doesn't have to be exactly
perfect.
Because it's like, oh yeah, there's a little brown and
there's a little pink and it's perfect.
Okay.
What did I?
Oh, there it is.
Uh.
Again, welcome back!
Thank you!
I don't want any...
any Sharpie color.
Pink must be preserved.
This is to here.
Like so?
It's like a little messy.
But like I said, I think it can't be helped with how her
hair is, but I definitely wanted to include the pink So I
think that's just how it's gonna be a little bit
Cute nails, thank you I'm surprised so many of you are
complimenting my nails Thank you Oh, I have the nail polish
actually right here If anybody is like, oh, I wonder what
color that is Because it's a cute color and I want to try it
Blah, blah, blah.
It's, uh, this Essie.
Essie.
Eternal.
Oh, you can't see it.
Eternal Optimist.
144.
Essie.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
There.
Is Essie durable?
Sssie.
I didn't put a top coat on.
So.
It does chip.
You know.
I feel like a lot of nail polish brands aren't super great.
If they're not like gel or something.
You know.
But I like the color so much.
I don't mind.
Yeah.
It's still a very pretty color.
I might even like kind of like have it cross like this.
You know.
So it has like a little bit of.
dimension.
Like have these two pieces like one like sticking out kind
of.
Let me glue these together then.
Good idea.
Thank you.
It looks like a funny mustache.
Phoebe feels closer to being done which is great.
Just a lot of gluing that we'll need to do.
And then we can start on Vicky.
I think I'll start on Vicky.
I'm not sure how much I'll get done of Vicky, sadly, but...
Sorry, Vicky, for being so dang slow.
I'm sorry.
I'll just post on Twitter when I finish them.
So you all can see.
Oh, yeah, I was going to do the braids, too.
There's one thing I want to do as well.
with Phoebe.
Puppet Minto?
I can show you in a second.
Yeah, that's so Phoebe.
With the pink.
Puppet Minto!
Yeah, Puppet Minto.
Actually, I realized I forgot to do the collar here.
I'll have to do that.
I'll fix that in.
Fill it in later.
So cute.
Honestly, I'm thinking of just leaving this like...
As is.
It kind of works.
I can, like, I can, like, glue it down.
But it, honestly, it kind of works.
Yeah, I'm a hair bow.
There's quite a bit of Minto that needs to be finished.
Alright.
Oh!
Oh, oh, I forgot to glue this.
I glued this one, right?
Yeah, okay.
Oops.
I think it's on.
There we go.
Sorry if I've been doing so much off the camera i don't even
realize sometimes okay uh huh huh uh huh
freaky light thank you i'm back from the arctic the sun
never set it worked me like a dog and i never saw a polar
bear i would go back again but i'm glad to be back to your
streets
That's so awesome!
Welcome back!
Are you sure they didn't see you?
Yeah, I want to see the northern lights!
Can we do an Ibu trip to the Arctic?
It's cheaper than going to the Antarctic as much as I would
love to go to the Antarctic with everybody.
Secret ghost!
Secret ghost.
Oh no!
I cover her!
Wait, we can fix this.
There we go.
We don't cover it.
I'm gonna make a new triangle.
It's so tiny.
I've been fennangling with it.
Need more white.
There we
go.
There we go.
are to work with.
And then we'll add a little pink guy here.
I was told you can't see the Northern Lights in the Arctic.
The Arctic?
What?
No.
That's why they're called the Northern Lights.
Oh, in the Arctic, though.
Oh, maybe, like, you were too high up.
Oh, maybe?
Maybe?
I don't know, actually, like...
How...
Yeah.
Gotta go to the North Pole.
Because, like, I know you can see the Northern Lights, like,
you know, Canada, like Finland, and stuff.
But...
That's kind of crazy, though.
If that's true, crazy, if real.
Like, you went too far north to see the Northern Lights.
Ibu Trip to...
To Iceland.
Are you guys seeing Phoebe now?
It's a way for strong magnetic storms.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Wait, this is the one that's on this side.
Yeah?
Yippee!
Did I glue this?
No.
I did glue this.
Um.
Alright, I'm getting ahead of myself with some of these
things.
Let's glue some of the sides of her hair down.
Her side burns.
The side burns.
There's so much glue.
The roar was visible across the majority of the state
several times in the last year or two.
Yeah, there's been like crazy magnetic storms like last
year.
remember because I kind of I like don't super track those
things but I'm interested in it you know so I like to track
it a little bit I've always wanted to see uh aurora lights
the aurora borealis in my kitchen and he never lets me see
it I say man I see it and he says no
almost glued the sharpie to oh oh I've glued the sharpie to
Phoebe okay we're fine
Skinner does a mean ham, though.
A mean steamed ham.
That was, I don't know if you heard that.
That was me dropping my Sharpie.
She is, oh my god, she's naked.
She's naked from behind.
Baby's ponytail is a little bit lower.
So we'll do, like, we'll do here.
And obviously when I complete the back side, we will...
I made it stick out a little bit more than I wanted to, but
that's okay.
I'll just cover it up.
Cool!
Alright.
Next is...
We'll do her collar.
Actually having the ghost makes me know which side is which,
which is really nice.
Cool!
Oh,
it dripped on her, on her chest.
Oh, I glued to Koharu.
Ow, Phoebe, ow, I'll take the pain for you.
It's okay, it didn't even leave a mark.
This finger, this finger, wait, you can't really tell that
it's, you can kind of see it's a little, not really.
It's a little bit redder than the others.
Koharu is also fine.
It was just a little bit of glue.
I think this part right here.
Yeah, that's okay.
I just realized I didn't do the triangle first.
Oh, shoot.
I think I'm an idiot.
Uh-oh.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
No!
I did glue the hair down.
Oh no!
No!
What am I supposed to do?
Oh shoot!
Wait, there's a small opening here.
Wait.
Glue for nothing.
Oh there's no opening here though.
I glued it too well.
Ah!
Yeah, I might have to cut it down to size and just kind of
squeeze it in there.
Oh man, I really didn't want to do that.
Oh, I meant don't glue the hair under the collar.
Thank you.
Shoot.
I'll just cut it.
It'll be easier.
If I have to cut another triangle, so be it.
You know?
Seeing if I can, like, how much of this I can shove in.
Oh, I really can't shove in anything.
No, I really messed up!
Oh, that sucks.
It's gonna look so ugly.
No, I'm so mad.
No, it looks so ugly.
No, it looks so ugly!
You can't really tell on your end because of the camera,
but...
It does not look good.
It's okay.
Dang it.
That makes me really mad.
Yeah, part of it will be covered by this thing.
That's kind of the one saving grace.
That's why I'm immediately putting it on because I don't
want to look at it anymore.
Oh, I'm so dumb.
I shouldn't have glued.
I shouldn't have glued them down.
I think it's probably something only I will notice, though.
So don't say anything to anybody.
okay this is our little secret it's our little secret
next is um one thing i do also want to do is Phoebe's got a
little like pink ahogue and I do like in the front of her
bangs and I do want to make that as well Like this part
right here.
Much cuter though.
Than however that was.
Like that.
I need to stop using this finger.
To touch everything.
There we go.
Like so.
Okay.
Alright.
The sacrificial fangler.
Um, then her...
We do these.
We do the flowers in her hair and the leaves.
Which...
Wait, now I'm missing another one.
Wait, I had five!
And now I'm down to three!
Wait!
Where did the other flowers go?
What the hell?
Hold on, let me check...
Oh, I found one on the floor.
Okay, hold on.
I found them.
I found two more.
Wait, won't it look kind of funny though if I did three on
this side and then only one here?
That would look kind of silly, no?
Okay, but also listen here.
Doki Bird has two.
Where, Doki?
Do you think she really needs this?
I only need one more.
Do kitty.
Where do kitty?
Yeah, she can donate.
She's not screaming in pain.
She's...
Everything's fine.
It's like...
It actually looks great.
It actually...
Yay!
It's the perfect amount!
Some of you may die, and that is a sacrifice I am willing to
make.
Very good.
Let me drink some more tea.
You guys like my cup?
It's one of my favorite mugs.
I like really big mugs, because I also...
I eat, like, everything out of mugs.
I eat cereal.
I eat soup.
I eat oatmeal.
I eat everything.
I drink tea out of mugs.
I love big, big mugs.
This is why Nimi needed...
She didn't retrieve her puppet.
I gave it to her.
Big difference.
Alright.
Well, and because we only have two on this side, we'll do
three leaves on this side.
And we'll do two leaves on this side.
Like so.
And then we'll do it kind of like how it is right here.
You can tell by the one on your desk?
Oh, yeah!
My coffee mug.
My coffee bucket.
She loves big mugs and cannot lie.
I cannot lie.
A big mug.
My other brothers can't deny when I walk into a kitchen and
the itty-bitty cupboard has a giant mug.
I stutter.
Oh my gosh, I'm too good at rapping.
Okay, I'm going to do it like that.
so good.
Wait a second.
I might have, I might have really cooked here.
I might have really cooked here.
The only thing that kind of sucks is, um, wait, where did
the other leaf go?
There.
Is her dress?
Kind of like cuts off from her.
It's kind of accurate to how her dress actually is though,
because it doesn't like go all the way up it does like kind
of just cut here um it does look a little bit silly but that
is how our actual dress is it just looks silly but it is how
our actual dresses i'm gonna glue these two while i am at it
i wonder which way looks better i might maybe i redo this
one
i'm not sure yet
I'm not sure yet.
Hmm.
Yeah, free the boots, free the boots!
I'll try redoing it.
I'm making it a bit wider.
Not satisfied with it.
My perfectionism is once again kicking in.
Oh wait, turn up.
Yeah.
Turned up.
I wish I could give this to, like, to them.
I almost wish that we got to keep our own.
They turned out so good.
Maybe I can do more in the future.
But it is a time-consuming process.
I think if I ever have it as, like, a merch thing, it will
be extremely...
Extremely limited quantities.
So, uh...
Ouch.
Which I do want to do them for my next outfit.
So, uh, heads up on that, I suppose.
If you want a handmade puppet of my next outfit.
Like, I should start working on them now.
Why is it so fuzzy?
Like...
Okay.
Let's do these last two leaves!
Okay, that's one.
And the second.
Ouch.
Okay.
Start up the sweatshop.
No!
Only I can realize my artistic potential, like my artistic
vision.
I'm one of those people that's like if I can't entrust this
to anybody else.
Only I can do it.
What's the new outfit exactly?
I don't know.
I'm giving no hints.
No help.
I don't know!
Okay, I'm making a new arm thingy.
I've decided.
I have decided.
I like cut out a new thing already.
So I'll just kind of do this.
Okay.
That's already better maybe smaller ruffles
like the other side and this one matches the other side
better i'd say yeah much better okay and then uh
out out of games to play wait you're out of games to play
Ace Combat, 7.
Yay!
Okay.
Yeah, Pragmat is another really good choice.
Unless you've already played it.
Yay!
Much better, much better, much better.
Satisfaction.
Oh, good, good, good.
I feel like...
Here...
I wonder if I can do like a fold of the like something like
like that even wait if I pinch it hold on hold on hold on
if I pinch it like that and I could do another tiny smaller
one here too how do I what do I cut for this though I kind
of, I took this and I folded it.
I took this and I folded it.
So, uh, where are my scissors?
Do you want to think, yeah?
How do I?
Let's just do like that.
Something like that?
Maybe.
Make like a little burrito.
Okay, let me try it.
It came through!
Wow!
Camp patrol, thank you!
And then I can stick it in there and do the like the monkey
monkey monkey monkey monkey monkey monkey monkey
there it's got like a little bit of dimension and now let's
do another one how did i okay i fold and i fold and we'll do
a small one here so such a strange cut i just cut because
there's like a small one over on this side too.
I don't know if it looks strange that there's only two that
there's... I don't know.
Her dress just has so much dimension that I feel like I need
to include it a little bit.
You know what I mean?
Maybe like that.
I don't know.
I'm attempting.
There's an attempt here.
There is an attempt here.
Oh, I made it back into a point.
I was trying to make it the second fold is like is like
curved like this yeah it is so flowy it is
I don't know if it looks weird though you know what I mean
like if it's like maybe just the one I don't know I feel
like maybe the second one is a little awkward looking I feel
like maybe just the one is okay I don't know I don't know
how I feel about the second one
like it feels out of place then
actually I can't even fit it in here
I can't even really fit it
closer to this one the second one starts to look like lapels
yeah like it just I don't mind it actually together but it
also doesn't really make much sense in terms of like how
fabric like Yeah, I think just the one kind of It's like You
get the intention But it's not overdoing it Does that make
sense?
Does that make sense?
Okay
Okay Yay!
And then I have that I have her mole I have this Um Okay Her
arm warmers, her hair.
Oh, with the braid.
Let's do that.
Makes sense.
Thanks, guys.
Let's see.
I have to cut three thin strips.
So one brown, two,
brown, and then one pink.
Nice glue gun.
Thanks.
What about my glue gun?
It intrigues you, huh?
What is it about my glue gun that intrigues you, huh?
How do you braid what not on hair?
Wait a second.
Okay, hold on.
I gotta braid my own hair real quick.
It's pink, duh.
I don't know how to do this.
Okay, hold on.
Wait.
I think if I glue them all together first.
At the top.
Right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's glue them together.
Ah!
Stop it.
Glue gun is...
Hot glue is amazing, except, like, why is it so stringy?
know why is it such a stringy uh glue you're
hot i
think i might be able to do this now oh stupid okay let's
move this over here
hmm it comes it's a it really comes in nice Honestly, more
towards the end, I feel.
This might as well be magic to me.
That's how you braid a hair.
I made it too long.
Let me hot glue it.
Do you guys not know?
Do you guys not know how to braid hair?
So funny.
Ouch.
At least it was my thumb this time.
I braided my hair.
Yeah.
There's lots of uses, lots of helpful, like, you know, it's
useful just in general to know how to braid.
But also, like, you know, it's kind of like, you know, like,
you can braid a rope.
You know?
I've braided my beard a couple times.
Yeah, see?
Something.
I wish we could make like a little tie around it.
That makes it look like it's, you know, tied.
Oh, I can!
With the gold!
Wait, it'll look so nice!
Wait, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
With the gold ribbon!
It'll look so cute.
Maybe even just like that.
I don't, I didn't do it.
Actually, here, let me undo it and retie it.
Make it look a little more even.
Uh...
Is that where he went?
Maybe?
It's so hard to do it.
It's so difficult.
Ow!
It's so difficult!
I love creative projects like this.
This is why this is like my element I feel, you know.
I'm very, you know, I'm more handy than like you know, some
people are really creative with like you know minecraft or
stuff like that but I I feel more in my element with like
actual arts and crafts so hard to tie though it's so hard to
make it to a ribbon it's so small it's so small I have to
double bunny ear it double bunnies oh gosh it's so small can
I Even getting it through the hole?
Can the bunny hide in the hole?
We can get there.
So close.
We might just have to keep it kind of...
It's a little funky looking, though.
And then...
Let's see.
We put it down here.
And then...
Oh my gosh, it looks so good!
It looks so good!
Okay, I'm gonna have to like glue probably the braids up
around here.
Just to hold them together.
So let's let that dry for a second.
Looks like Phoebe!
I know!
Oh!
It does!
Phoebe!
Okay, all right.
None.
I'll cut this.
It does still need to be cut a little bit more.
Uh, hmm.
Hmm.
Just making sure, you know, Handy is good at crafts.
Handy is putting your hands on people in questionable ways.
What?
No!
No, you're handsy with...
Wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no,
no.
Minto has become the HR issue.
No!
Wait, are you guys being for real, or am I getting gaslit by
everybody in chat right now?
Wait, so if I'm like, oh, I'm...
It's real.
Wait, so, wait, hold on.
You said the one for crafts is what?
Handy.
I thought that's if you're like a tool man.
Like, hi, I'm the tool man.
I'm handy.
No.
I feel like I'm getting gaslit.
you also use tools for crafts no I'm doing crafts I'm doing
crafts crafts are crafts and tools are tools that tools is
like a hammer if I use a hammer then it's it's got to be for
crap if it's got it's no I'm handsy I'm handsy I thought it
was just a cute way what the hell wait I I thought it was
like a cute way of saying it.
I thought you were just doing a freaky bit this whole time.
I'm not!
They are in fact handicrafts and not handsy crafts.
This is not cuter to say, oh, I'm handsy.
No,
no, can I keep saying handsy anyway then?
Who knows?
He even tells the difference.
Who can even tell the difference?
You guys didn't know until...
Wait, how did you guys know?
Where did you guys learn that?
Is that common knowledge?
That everybody knows Hansi?
Oops.
It's common!
I think it's cute, but just...
No.
Why did the cuter version become the one that the perverts
use?
Oh my gosh.
Keep saying handsy, don't change.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna try one more time to make this a cute little
ribbon.
I'm gonna put the bunny in the hole.
The other way did not work for me.
It's so hard to tell what's the bunny.
All the gold is so, like, it blends in and it sparkles and
it's so hard to tell.
Okay, hold on.
Bunny ear, bunny ear.
Loop the bunny.
Bunny into the hole.
Bunny in the hole.
Fire.
Fire in the hole.
Ah!
I give up.
Minto, you are the perverts.
But I wasn't trying to be.
Maybe I'm just a natural pervert.
Oh, man.
I think one day I'm going to get arrested.
I will.
Then we'll be on accident.
I'm not trying to get arrested.
I'm not trying to get arrested, Your Honor.
It's just in my DNA.
We've been saying this actually.
Who is we?
The polls.
You know those betting websites?
People are betting on whether I'll get arrested in the next
five years or not.
We've been saying this.
I've bet my entire life savings on it actually.
we've been saying this you're gonna get arrested a little
freak azoid pervert you're such a pervert you can't even
help yourself just comes naturally handsy I was made after
you that was made because of you you little freak come on
bunny get And then the whole...
And then the whole bunny.
So close.
It looks ugly.
Your Honor.
You wasn't even there.
This is why she doesn't talk to the external vendors.
Oh, but you're allowed to?
Look at how good Phoebe looks!
Steiner!
Look how good she looks.
Look at my Phoebe.
Look, actually, it turned out kinda cute.
I kept it.
I just gotta put the eyes on her.
It completes the look.
Looks just like her.
Look at me!
Does this look like me?
How did you transpose yourself on the camera feed like that?
I'm right here.
Steiner.
I don't think he'd be able to tell which is real.
I don't think he'd be able to know.
It's crazy.
Look just like you.
That's what I'm saying.
Steiner, can I make merch of this for my next outfit?
Of my next outfit?
I wonder if I made her...
I feel like Phoebe's bangs are a little long.
I think it's okay.
You need permission?
I own him, so if I say I want to do it, I'll say make it
work.
But I'm just asking out of courtesy.
Where is... Oh, there's my Sharpie.
Okay, I'm going to give Phoebe a cute little smile.
Oh, employed.
Sorry, I'm new to this.
Sorry.
What kind of smile...
Okay, I need your guys' help.
What kind of smile are we thinking?
Well, approved.
follow your dreams mass production funding not guaranteed no
i would only make a couple i'll probably make like 10.
20 if i have time all right guys do we go with a smile kind
of like this
or a smaller like like that Triangle?
Phoebe does not have a triangle mouth.
For smile.
I mean, she can also be mouth wide open too.
Hold on.
I'm cutting it so we can get like a good, you know?
A good everything.
Yeah.
So there's that.
Or...
The count.
Why does this one look so...
Pick number one, my lord.
Wait, hold on.
I kind of also want to see an open mouth.
I can imagine the bloodbath.
That would be the auction selling of the...
I'm sorry.
I can't...
I'm not a machine.
Wait.
Open is pretty cute, too.
I feel like all of us should be open mouth.
I think all of us will end up open mouth.
Okay.
Open mouth!
We're all excitable.
It's because it's more puppets.
When you use a puppet, you're just like, I'm talking!
So it has to be open mouth, you know?
It makes more sense in puppet lore.
Oh, it looks so cute!
It looks so good!
A raffle would probably be the best way to preserve lives.
Where it's still in states.
It's in the planning stages.
Phoebe!
Say suva!
Except she was second.
Oh, thank you!
Vito!
Hi, Phoebe.
Uh-oh.
She's got a lazy eye, you guys.
Only one of her eyes moves.
Hold on.
We're in crisis mode?
Uh-oh.
Only one of her eyes moves.
Uh oh.
She's got a lazy eye.
What do I do?
How do I fix that?
Oh no.
Flick it?
Oh!
Hi, Vito!
Yay.
Yay!
That's two made!
Last step.
Is Vicky.
Oh my gosh, it's almost 1 a.m.
Oh.
Vicky might have to be...
What do I do?
I'm thinking.
Did you finish your taco?
I finished my taco.
I did not finish my five letter.
I'm not...
I feel like I can keep going, but I...
I'm also going to cut Phoebe's bangs a little bit.
But like I said, I wanted to earlier.
Hold on.
Sorry, I gotta like get in there.
Yeah.
I might also do the same thing for Phoebe that I did for me,
where I like kind of gave myself some like little cuts.
So let me do that real quick too.
And then I also gotta shorten her little Ahoye.
There we go.
And let me do some quick little cuts here.
I'm almost there.
One second.
Yeah.
Very nice.
What's the plan now, boss?
I'm still thinking.
I'd like to start on Vicky at least.
Let me pull up her.
I'm trying to do the version with the cape.
How am I supposed to make her boobs?
Enhance.
Yeah, I'll enhance.
I just don't want to... I have some stuff I need to do.
Actually, I have a lot of stuff that I need to do tomorrow.
I think I might actually have to call it here.
I'm sorry, guys.
I just remembered that I do have things to do.
do tomorrow.
I'll...
I just remembered her schedule.
I have...
Yeah.
I have some recording I need to do.
That will take me about...
Probably like five-ish.
Four, five hours.
Before stream.
So, it's hard to say.
I think, um, I don't think I have enough time to do a last
stream before I go to Japan to finish Vicky.
I'm really sorry.
Obakas, I think I will not have time.
But of course I will take pictures once I'm done.
I could maybe actually squeeze into a double stream.
I will try.
I will try double stream.
Because it's just one.
It's just one.
So I think, let me finish Vicky Puppet.
I'll put it in my calendar.
Hmm.
Double layer and stuff with cotton.
That's a great idea.
So I will do that.
Especially, I'll be gone.
Well, yeah, I...
It should be okay.
Yeah.
I'm trying to plan out when I'm...
filming for the let's play as well while I'm gone so it's
just one but it took two to three hours I think once I'm in
the groove it's better it's better it's a great vitamin
there as the Japanese might say make sure to pace yourself
everyone thinks you're doing awesome what is this sarcasm is
this sarcasm is this sarcasm
It's not sarcasm.
I'll figure it out.
I'll do what I can on these two, finishing the backs off
stream.
And then for Vicky, I'll try to do the whole thing.
thing on stream good luck with vicky thanks for the stream
happy may happy may happy may thank you thank you thank you
sorry guys it took me six hours three hours each for uh it
seems like it but no i think we'll be okay with vicky i
think we got this oh my gosh sorry guys thank you you're so
good at this i have a dark pink donut oh no whoever wins
will be so lucky please do us a favor and tell the nice girl
you possess thanks and that she has pretty hands please
possess her to get good sleep as a reward for her work okay
okay thank you doryko thank you so much for that guys super
thank you
uh yeah i'm gonna finish my five later with that one a.m and
go to bed Minto, thank you for the concert.
Oh, she up, like, safe travels.
Thank you, oh, she up, like, thank you, thank you, thank
you.
Yeah, I think I'm really, really happy with how they both
turned out.
I think they're so stinking cute.
I think Phoebe's is like, the hair is so good.
I might probably like cut this part too.
I might like blend it a little bit more, but it ended up
being so cute.
I'm so happy with it.
cute too so many details so shiny um yeah i'm really happy
with how they turned out
they're so funny
the googly eyes are cute i think so too yay thank you guys
thank you thank you yeah but i see i don't know if the if
the Dono will show up, but thank you so much for the
Akadono.
Thank you!
Great handsy work today, Minto.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Work has been keeping me away, but I'm still here.
Thank you, Manji!
Thank you.
Really appreciate it.
Awesome.
Then, next week we will finish up Vicky and um Yeah, I got
I've got a before I go to bed I've got to put on the collar
it looks so goofy She looks like She looks like a thumb
without it
But luckily I didn't Glue these down so I can make it really
easy Fast and easy But yeah, thank you everybody Thank you,
thank you so much Have a good night, thank you for the long
stream I had a lot of fun We'll see, tomorrow's Deadly
Premonition I was gonna make it a long stream We'll see how
my throat is after Recording and everything too But I could
also push record Well no I can't We'll see Okay Bye-bye
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye
Bye-bye Onzorito on-zorito Thank you everybody Get some good
brass Get some good Good luck, guys, and bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye, bye, bye-bye.